bonjour et bonne rentrée j'imagine que
comme moi vous êtes en train de
réacquérir après deux mois passés à
oublier toutes les vicissitudes de ce
monde
je vais donc vous parler ce matin
d'énergie et j'aurai à peu près réussi
mon coup si à la fin de cet exposé petit
à vous avez beaucoup plus de questions
que vous n'en aviez en entrant petit b
vous comprenez que dès qu'il ya une
évolution dans le monde qui nous entoure
qu'on a du mal à comprendre
il est possible qu'ils aient de
l'énergie qui se cache derrière est
petit c'est si je réussis à faire dévier
la carrière de l'un d'entre vous au
moins de l'un d'entre vous de ce que
vous avez initialement en tête
alors comme vous l'avez compris je suis
un expert mondialement connue mais je
vais quand même appelé à la rescousse
pour le début de cet exposé quelqu'un
qui est beaucoup plus connu que moi donc
je vous présente le premier professeur
de france premier professeur de france
comme vous le savez officie une fois par
mois à 20h30 donc c'est à une heure où
normalement vous vous avez plus court et
le premier professeur de france pose des
questions qui après la réponse est et
qui part dont la réponse devient un
inconnu de quelques millions de français
pose une question puis après quelques
millions de français qui connaissent la
réponse
moi j'en suis malheureusement pas encore
là mais on va imaginer qu'il pose la
question qu'il n'a jamais posé de
mémoire dans son émission et de manière
ouverte qui est d'après vous de quoi
parle-t-on quand on parle d'énergie
qu'est ce que c'est que l'énergie alors
imaginez que le parisien face un sondage
et demandez aux français
qu'est ce que c'est que l'énergie et
bien je vous fiche mon billet et je suis
prêt à parier toutes mes économies plus
les vôtres que la première réponse qui
va venir à l'esprit des français c'est
ça l'énergie c'est une facture c'est un
truc que je paye ça s'appelle
l'électricité si le président d'edf sans
visa envisage pardon du reste
d'augmenter le prix de l'électricité il
saute dans la demi heure
ça s'appelle du pétrole éventuellement
encore ça s'appelle du gaz donc ça
s'appelle un truc que je paye vous avez
un sous-ensemble de la population
beaucoup plus restreint chez qui le
réflexe pavlovien n'est pas facture mais
économies énergies les gens me répondent
économie quoi quand comment pourquoi
devient un débat parfois plus complexe
mais en gros premier truc qui leur vient
à l'esprit c'est qu'il faut l'économiser
et puis vous avez des poètes qui vont
vous dit
voilà ce que c'est que l'énergie donc si
vous n'avez pas trop fait la fête hier
soir
voilà la définition vous pourriez me
donner de l'énergie à un matin vous êtes
en forme c'est ce dont vous êtes remplit
ses salles énergie et bien figurez vous
que les deux premiers ont tort et que le
poète a raison puisque si vous vous
rappelez un tout petit peu de vos vieux
souvenirs de physique qui normalement
vous ont servi à quelque chose pour
venir jusqu'ici
eh bien vous vous rappellerez que
l'énergie c'est par définition ce qui
caractérise le changement du monde donc
c'est aussi par définition ce qui
organise le monde donc le poète a raison
quand vous êtes plein d'énergie vous
avez une capacité à tout transformer les
deux autres ont tort
accessoirement ou le paye et
accessoirement il faut éventuellement
l'économiser dans certaines
circonstances on va donc revenir à deux
choses je vais pas m'éloigner beaucoup
durant cet exposé parce que j'ai oublié
les matches compliqués que je faisais à
votre époque
donc je vais revenir à deux choses
extrêmement simple qui sont la première
loi de la thermo et la règle de trois et
vous allez voir que je vais à peu près
tout faire pendant cet exposé avec la
première de la thermos et la règle de
trois
donc l'énergie même si elle a pas de
définition formelle ou plus exactement
même si un certain nombre de physiciens
lui donne des définitions un peu
différente elle en gros ma définition à
moi c'est que l'énergie c'est la
grandeur qu'on utilise pour caractériser
le changement d'état d'un système en
physique c'est ça l'énergie c'est la
grandeur qu'on utilise pour caractériser
le changement d'état d'un système dit
autrement dès que quelque chose change
quelque part vous avez de l'énergie et
surtout symétriquement dès que vous avez
de l'énergie quelque chose change donc
l'idée que vous avez de l'énergie propre
c'est à dire qu'ils ne changeraient rien
céder qui laisserait les toilettes dans
l'état dans lequel on il a trouvé en
entrant ça n'existe pas ça ne peut pas
exister à cause de la définition même de
l'énergie quelques exemples issus de la
vie courante ou vous voyez bien un
système qui change et donc de l'énergie
qui intervient quand vous avez une
température qui change dans un système
c'est une pièce par exemple eh bien vous
avez de l'énergie qui entrent en jeu
quand vous avez la vitesse relative d'un
objet qui change eh bien vous avez de
l'énergie qui entrent en jeu
quand vous avez une forme qui changent
vous avez de l'énergie qui entrent en
jeu vous avez dans l'industrie les tetra
chier de machines dont la fonction est
de changer la forme d'un objet quand
vous avez une composition chimique qui
changent vous avez de l'énergie qui
entrent en jeu et les fameuses calories
qui passionne tant les magazines
féminins à partir du mois de mai
peut-être encore au mois de septembre
soit dit en passant
ne sont rien d'autre que la capacité à
fournir de l'énergie des molécules qu'on
ingère et l'énergie en question va nous
servir essentiellement à chauffer notre
corps un tout petit peu à réfléchir et à
se déplacer quand vous avez un corps qui
interagit avec un champ vous avez de
l'énergie qui entrent en jeu donc quand
je vais monter les marches de l'escalier
là pour sortir ce temps fuit parce que
j'espère que je serai encore vivant à la
fin de cette conférence
eh bien je vais mammas va interagir avec
le champ gravitationnel et ça va me
demander de l'énergie est symétriquement
si je me casse la figure je restitue de
l'énergie en arrivant en bas ça marche
aussi évidemment avec les électrons les
champs magnétiques
quand vous avez une composition atomique
qui change vous avez de l'énergie qui
entrent en jeu et incidemment toutes
absolument toutes les énergies que nous
utilisons sur terre sont des dérivés
directe ou indirecte de l'énergie
nucléaire absolument tout
et enfin quand vous avez de
l'interaction matière rayonnement vous
avez aussi de l'énergie qui entrent en
jeu donc ça c'est la version très
sympathique à laquelle vous n'avez pas
manqué de sacrifier pendant les deux
mois qui viennent de s'écouler
vous avez une version plus quotidienne
qui est l'utilisation du four à
micro-ondes dans lequel il faut pas
mettre les charges vous rappelle ou la
découpe des tissus au laser c'est
également de l'interaction matière
rayonnement en bref vous en avez un
certain nombre donc je le répète compter
l'énergie ses comptes et la
transformation compter la transformation
ses comptes et l'énergie je le répète il
n'y a pas d'énergie propre il n'y a pas
non plus d'énergie sales tout est une
affaire d'ordre de grandeur et de
caractéristiques vous ne sortez jamais
d'un débat sur l'énergie sans avoir
manipulé des chiffres un débat sur
l'énergie dans lequel on n'a pas
manipulé deux chiffres et un débat qui
ne vaut rien et un débat qui ne vaut
rien autre petite conclusion que je peux
vous livrer tout de suite
le premier principe de la thermo sera
toujours plus fort que les promesses
politiques toujours donc toute promesse
politique qui présuppose de violer le
premier principe de la thermo fera
faillite
et je suis toujours prêt à parier la
totalité de ma fortune sur le fait que
ça ne marchera pas toujours je vous ai
dit on peut pas sortir d'un débat sur
l'énergie sans avoir manipulé des ordres
de grandeur or là je vais en manipuler
un premier qui est tout simplement de
comparer l'énergie que votre carcasse
est la mienne votre carcasse un peu plus
que la mienne des plus jeunes est
capable de fournir dans une journée de
dur labeur
voilà un exercice auquel certains
d'entre vous se sont peut-être livré cet
été qui consiste à se lever fort taux
sinon vous prenez des coups de soleil et
vous transpirez un peu plus à mettre un
sac sur le dos et à faire en sorte que
votre corps lutte contre le chanteur
avait stationné ce qui s'appelle faire
d'un montagne alors on va imaginer c'est
pas du tout sexy c'était juste parce que
ça tomberont que vous peser 80 kg on va
imaginer que votre sac
en fait 10 et on va imaginer que vous
faites de ville va être dans la journée
qui a fait 2000 mètres dans la journée
cet été donc vous raconterez aux autres
quand on arrive au refuge où au sommet
on est content de ce soir on a quand
même transpirer un petit coup et bien
quand vous faites cet exercice là qui
est quand même un truc encore une fois
qui représente un pas un exploit mais
enfin quelque chose de raisonnablement
sympathique sur le plan sportif tout ce
que vos jambes ont fourni c'est un
ridicule demi kilowattheures d'énergie
mécanique transpirer pendant une journée
vous faites 2000 mètres de dénivelé
sénégal mgh instrus facile à faire
alors j'ai d'exiger dans cette affaire
le fait que votre corps fait toujours un
tout petit peu plus que l'altitude que
vous gagnez pas ce que vous lisez un
tout petit peu au dessus des cailloux
sinon vous casser la figure
mais enfin en première approximation
2000 mètres de dénivelé pour un individu
normalement constitué
c'est à dire qu'il peut se passe en 50
kg ou qui n'empêche pas 30 et bien c'est
un devis kilowattheures d'énergie
mécanique fournis par vos jambes
imaginez que vous fassiez ça un jour sur
deux tous les jours que dieu fait ce qui
revient à dire que vous faites une
grosse étape du gr20 tous les jours de
l'année du 1er janvier au 31 décembre
et bien à la fin de l'année votre
carcasse aura fourni de l'ordre de 100
kilowatts heure d'énergie mécanique
encore 100 kilowatts heure d'énergie
mécanique
imaginons maintenant que vous n'allez
pas faire de la montagne vous fait
plaisir de vieille grand-mère qui
avaient implanté des géraniums et vous
fait un gros trou dans lequel vous des
quais ses six mètres cubes de terre six
mètres cubes de terre ça fait à peu près
15 tonnes toujours pareil à l'aide grh
vous remonter quinze contre quinze
tonnes de terre de 1 mètre de hauteur
vous faites le calcul comme moi ça fait
0,05 kilowattheures d'énergie mécanique
restituer même si vous avez les bras
schwarzenegger si vous faites ça un jour
sur deux 10 kilowatts heure d'énergie
mécanique dans l'année donc retenait
qu'un homme
travail ou une femme au travail
utilisant ses seuls muscles l'ordre de
grandeur de l'énergie c'est à dire de la
transformation de l'environnement qu'il
va pouvoir fournir se baladent quelque
part entre quelques dizaines et une
grosse centaine de kilowattheures
maintenant je vais prendre un litre de
pétrole
un litre de pétrole comme vous le savez
coûte scandaleusement cher du reste - ça
coûte cher mieux on se porte
et dans un litre de pétrole si vous le
faites brûler en totalité vous avez dit
kilowattheures de chaleur fait passer ça
dans un moteur conçu par un ingénieur à
peu près normalement constitué et vous
en tirerez 2 à 4 kilowatts heure façon
carnot dit que vous allez pas en tirer
du kilowattheure de mouvement vous en
tirez 2 à 4 kilowatts heure de
mouvements d'énergie mécanique c'est à
dire que dans un seul litre de pétrole
dont un français consomme mille 400
litres par an en plus de toutes les
autres énergies
vous avez la même capacité à transformer
l'environnement que dans 10 à 100 jours
de travail de force d'un être humain
dans un litre de pétrole
un seul si je traduis ça en termes
économiques
vous savez que normalement on n'est pas
censé payer les gens moins que le smic
dans notre pays si vous le faites ne le
dites à personne si je paye mon
individus au smic et que tout ce qui
m'intéresse c'est d'obtenir la
transformation de l'environnement
je veux pas le faire réfléchir j'ai
juste le faire bosser et bien à ce
moment je vais payer mon kilowattheures
d'énergie mécanique de quelques
centaines à quelques milliers d'euros
quelques centaines à quelques milliers
d'euros en face de ça la machine me
fournit le même service à 1 euro 50 le
litre de pétrole pour quelques dizaines
de centimes en coût marginal je n'ai pas
compté la machine dans cette histoire
mais en coût marginal quelques dizaines
de centimes
dit autrement pétrole gaz charbon et
leurs petits copains
aujourd'hui permis de transformer
l'environnement pour un coût unitaire
qui est de quelques centaines à quelques
milliers de fois inférieures à ce que
l'homme est capable de faire la totalité
de ce qui fait votre univers aujourd'hui
vient de là je dis bien la totalité le
fait que vous ayez du temps pour faire
vos études que vous ayez
moyens de prendre l'avion que vous ayez
20 mètres carrés habitables par personne
que vous ayez des vêtements à profusion
que vous mangez de la viande à tous les
repas que vous viviez 70 ans et c est
loin de vos parents tout ça vient de
l'énergie tout tout tout tout les
revendications du medef et de la cgt et
les promesses électorales en viennent
tous et c'est ce que je vais essayer de
vous expliquer maintenant
avant je vais faire un petit détour
parfaitement immoral qui consiste à
regarder ce que ça coûte avec un esclave
alors évidemment cela vous avez
normalement c'est interdit dans notre
pays mais enfin on va quand même se
livrer à l'exercice esclaves comme vous
le savez sauf dans quelques clubs
sado-maso c'est pas une vocation de
jeunesse en général les gens sont pas
d'accord pour être esclaves
donc quand vous avez besoin d'un esclave
il faut aller le chercher contre sa
volonté ce qui va vous coûter un peu
d'argent où il faut payer quelqu'un qui
va le faire ce qui va vous coûter
éventuellement encore plus d'argent
puisqu'elle sa marge
une fois qu'il est esclave il ya phare
l'empêcher de [ __ ] le camp parce que
encore une fois c'est pas une vocation
donc il n'a pas très envie et puis il va
quand même falloir le nourrir et cetera
pour éviter qu'ils meurent parce que
sinon vous perdez votre actif et bien si
vous faites ce calcul parfaitement
sordide j'en conviens mais si vous le
faites quand même vous vous rendez
compte que même à l'esclave va vous
coûter 10 à 100 fois plus cher que la
machine donc une des conclusions que je
vous propose dès à présent c'est que
l'esclavagisme n'a pas disparu dans
notre place dans notre monde parce que
rousseau avait raison je ne pense pas
que le code génétique des hommes soient
fondamentalement différent de ce qu'il
était il ya huit générations
je pense que l'esclavagisme a disparu
parce que ça n'a strictement aucun
intérêt de s'emmerder à payer plus cher
pour faire des choses qui sont pas
commodes
encore une fois les capturer des gens
les empêcher de [ __ ] le camp et c'est
alors que la machine qui ne se met pas
en grève qui travaillent toute la nuit
et qui ne rouspète pas bouffer le même
job pour 10 à 100 fois moins cher c'est
le pétrole qui a supprimé l'esclavagisme
ce n'est pas notre code génétique qui a
changé parlons un peu de puissance donc
voilà ce qu est l énergie parfaitement
renouvelables avant que pétrole gaz et
charbon s'en mêle et on avait des
machines qui vous dégageait 100 watts de
puissance au maximum éventuellement des
animaux domestiques et qui vous
déployer un kilowatt au maximum tout ça
était pas terrible alors que maintenant
on sait faire beaucoup mieux
par exemple prenez un tracteur et bien à
tracteur a une puissance de quelques
dizaines de kilos watts plus de sens si
vous êtes un gros céréaliers donc ça
vous développe la même puissance que
quelques centaines de bons hommes où une
centaine de chevaux pour évidemment
considérablement moins chers pour
évidemment considérablement moins chers
donc donné les tracteurs aux
agriculteurs et vous verrez vous virer
90% ou 95% des paysans deschamps c'est
l'énergie qui a fait l'exode rural j'y
reviendrai juste après un engin de
chantier dont certains d'entre vous que
certains d'entre vous utiliseront
peut-être de manière indirecte dans
quelques années
eh bien ça vous développe une puissance
d'une centaines de kilowatts
c'est à dire que savoure en place selon
vous utilisez des jambes ou des bras
1000 à 10000 personnes
si aujourd'hui on devait construire une
tour à la défense avec les techniques
constructives des pyramides
c'est à dire les pierres extraites à la
main des carrières transportés sur des
barges monte à la main par des poulies
assemblé à la main et cetera la tour à
la défense elle prendrait pas s'ils vont
être construites 50 ans prendrait et ça
serait pas le même prix un camion
développe quelques milliers de fois la
puissance des jambes de son conducteur
donc là c'est pareil c'est pas les
camionneurs qui transportent les camions
qui transportent le camionneur et jouent
un jeu vidéo
il a un gros joystick qui s'appelle un
volant et puis il a des petits jeux
politiques qui s'appelle le changement
de vitesse le gps de machin le truc et
le bidule et donne des ordres la machine
c'est la machine qui bossent un avion
développe la même puissance qu'un
million de fois les jambes de son pilote
est du reste la puissance d'un jet de
ligne est à peu près la même que celle
d'un laminoir industriels qui lui
martèle comme 10 millions de paires de
bras donc dit autrement si les laminoirs
n'existait pas dans ce pays
et bien pour produire la même quantité
d'acier laminé on vous fait pas faire
des études
on prendrait toute l'île de france on
lui donnerait un marteau et on l'a frais
martelé sur des tôles 10 millions de
personnes
et ça ça vous l'amènerai la même
quantité d'acier car laminoir
industrielle pilotées par une personne
une dans une cabine de pilotage d'un ami
noir vous avez une personne
donc aujourd'hui ceux qui bossent c'est
plus nous c'est les machines nous on est
juste là pour donner des ordres aux
machines et ça explique soit dit en
passant quelque chose que je vous
montrerai un peu plus tard qui est
pourquoi l'emploi dépend non pas de chez
pas quoi et du plan politique du moment
l'emploi ne dépend que d'une seule chose
désormais c'est du nombre de machines
qui peuvent fonctionner un emploi c'est
un serviteur de machines moins d'énergie
moins de machines moins d'emplois ça
marche très très bien
et partout avant d'y venir
regardons un peu le passé vous avez ici
la quantité d'énergie qui est mobilisée
par terriens et par an alors immobilisé
et pas consommer c'est à dessein parce
que sauf erreur de ma part vous ne buvez
pas le pétrole vous ne mangez pas le
charbon vous ne resterez pas le gaz et
vous mettez pas vos doigts dans la prise
électrique je vous déconseille
formellement de dernier donc l'énergie
ou de la consommer pas vous l'énergie
vous la mobiliser pour la donner à
manger à des machines d'accord donc
quand on dit que les hommes consomment
de l'énergie
c'est un terme impropre on devrait dire
les hommes mobilise de l'énergie donc
cette énergie mobilisés par terriens ou
disponibles par terriens on va dire
voici comment elle a évolué sur un
siècle et demi d'eau il ya un siècle et
demi on avait à peu près mille 500
kilowatts heure par personne à notre
disposition sur une année cette énergie
était constituée à peu près à parité de
bois et charbon et on la donne est
essentiellement à manger à des machines
qui produisait de la chaleur c'est à
dire des poils domestique et un peu à
des machines qui produisait du mouvement
des pompes pour assécher les mines des
paquebots d'être un des maîtres des
voitures mais on a même essayé de faire
voler un avion avec une machine à vapeur
etc
et puis vous voyez que la quantité de
charbon disponibles par personne
augmente se stabilise pendant à peu près
un siècle
ils recommencent à augmenter sur les dix
dernières années retenez bien ce si la
quantité de charbon utilisé par personne
n'a jamais décru depuis que nous
utilisons du charbon et la quantité de
charbon utilisé dans le monde n'a jamais
décru depuis que nous utilisons du
charbon quand j'étais jeune on entend
des jeux passionnants tendait encore
maintenant que le charbon est une
énergie du passé ou jeu pourquoi c'est
absolument pas une énergie du passé en
fait c'est bien d'une énergie du présent
et la raison à cela c'est qu'après avoir
fait fonctionner des trains ce qui n'est
plus le cas aujourd'hui l'essentiel du
charbon sert surtout à produire de
l'électricité
viendrez un peu plus tard mais le
charbon et de très très loin la première
source de production électrique dans le
monde et non seulement c'est la première
mais c'est celle qui croît le plus vite
d'un absent tout ce que les journaux
peuvent vous raconter sur les éoliennes
et les panneaux solaires là dessus est
venue se rajouter le pétrole qui
n'alimente pas les mêmes machines le
pétrole alimente les machines à se
déplacer et non pas des machines à faire
de l'électricité le pétrole et l'énergie
reine des transports 98% de ce qui roule
vol ou david utilise du pétrole dans le
monde du pétrole des échanges pas de
pétrole pas des changes
c'est très simple du pétrole des
échanges pas de pétrole pas des gens
vous voyez plus généralement toutes les
énergies que nous utilisons aujourd'hui
se sont empilées les unes sur les autres
elles ne se sont pas du tout
cannibaliser sauf petite exception est
ce que vous voyez tout en haut là le
bleu c'est ramener à chaque terrien
l'éolien le photovoltaïque le marais
moteur le biogaz la géothermie l'énergie
des vagues l'énergie de la houle
l'hydrolien laurent fabre à tous les
machins qui excite les journalistes est
bien ramené à l'individu c'est le truc
bleus vous avez en haut on finira à la
fin de cet exposé par une petite règle
de trois
pour voir si effectivement ça ça va
faire de la croissance verte est
supprimé tout le reste dans les 25 ans
qui viennent
je vous rappelle que si ça ne passe pas
la règle de trois ans a fait faillite
un point absolument essentiel à noter
sur ce graphique c'est que vous voyez
que pendant un siècle la quantité
d'énergie disponible par personne donc
plus exactement pour le marque pour le
parc de machines par personne augmente
de 2 et demi pour cent par an c'est de
très très loin le premier terme
d'augmentation de la productivité du
travail sur cette période plus j'ai
d'énergie plus se faire fonctionner deux
machines plus je peux faire fonctionner
deux machines plus la production est
élevé ramenée à l'individu la production
augmente donc sur toute cette période
le premier terme d'augmentation de la
productivité c'est pas du tout de génie
des ingénieurs ou des économistes enfin
ou plus exactement c'est le génie d'une
seule catégorie d'ingénieurs c'est ce
qui arrive à faire en sorte qu'on ait
tapé de plus en plus vite dans les
stocks existants d'énergie tout le reste
suit est vrai que depuis les chocs
pétroliers
on a perdu un ordre de grandeur dans le
rythme de croissance et dans les pays de
l' ocde on a perdu tous les ordres de
grandeur puisque la consommation
d'énergie par personne et suivez moi
j'ai utilisé le mot qui n'allait pas
l'énergie utilisée par personne est
restée stable
de quand date l'endettement des états de
quand date la baisse de la productivité
du travail de quand date la
désindustrialisation de quand date
l'arrêt de la croissance à 5 % par an
etc des chocs pétroliers pas parce que
le prix du pétrole est monté plus
redescendu je vous montrerai après que
ça ça n'a strictement aucune espèce
d'importance parce que le rythme en ce
qui concerne l'approvisionnement
énergétique par personne a complètement
changé et ont tous les ans on pense que
l'année prochaine ça reviendra
est ce que je vais vous montrer un peu
plus tard c'est que ça ne reviendra plus
il n'en reste pas moins que aujourd'hui
et quand si vous observez attentivement
ce graphique vous voyez que là ça se
tasse un peu sur les deux dernières
années
pour ceux d'entre vous qui lisent un peu
la presse économique
vous entendez peut-être parler en ce
moment du ralentissement de l'économie
mondiale et cetera
je n'allais pas le chercher ailleurs il
est là il est là
il n'en reste pas moins que nous avons
grâce à l'énergie atteint ce qu'on peut
appeler denis un niveau de vie qui est
sans précédent dans l'histoire humaine
et qui fait ce que je vais dire est
politiquement évidemment abominable que
le smicard français vit aujourd'hui
comme un nabab
je dis bien comme un nabab il s'en rend
pas compte
ils pensent que c'est dégueulasse qui en
est qui vivent encore mieux que lui mais
il vit comme un nabab si je traduis
l'énergie disponible par terriens en
équivalent exclame rangement un bonhomme
10 à 100 kilowatts heure par an on en
consomme 20 mille kilowattheures
d'énergie par an donc ça fait
fonctionner autant de machines et bien
les êtres humains sur cette planète
vivent désormais comme si il existait
une exoplanète peuplé de 1400 milliards
de bons hommes pédalant toute la journée
et leur envoyant l'énergie
correspondante
je vous le redis autrement un terrien
vit en moyenne comme s'il avait 200
esclaves à disposition et un français
vit en moyenne comme s'il en avait 6 ans
et vous c'est plutôt mille puisque vous
faites partie des csp +
c'est ça la réalité que l'énergie nous
offre aujourd'hui nous vivons tous comme
si nous avons une armée
je dis bien une armée d'esclaves à
disposition ce qui soit dit en passant
était aussi le cas des citoyens libres
athéniens et romain je suis comme vous
le savez les citoyens libres était une
petite poignée entouré d'une armée
d'esclaves et de paysans qui était pas
du tout libre et qui triait comme des
bêtes
moyennant quoi les citoyens libres
nourris et logés et vêtu par tous ces
braves gens avaient le temps de discuter
des affaires de la cité
et on en est exactement au même point
aujourd'hui on en est exactement au même
point aujourd'hui je le redis le smicard
français vit comme un nabab
il a 40 mètres carrés d'espacé habitable
chauffée et refroidi même un noble du
moyen-âge n'avait pas ça c'est à dire
qu'ils avaient éventuellement un bout de
château qui était chauffé mais pour le
reste il se plaît il à 75 ans
d'espérance de vie à la naissance
l'espérance de vie à la naissance en
1800 dans les villes c'était 25 ans il a
accès à l'éducation il a accès aux jeux
du cirque dans son salon ça s'appelle
une télévision il a accès à l'orchestré
philharmonique dans sa cuisine ça
s'appelle une radio
il a accès à 30 kg de viande par
personne et par an de viande rouge par
dont 100 kg tout mouillé enfin 90
maintenant 90 il ya des belges donc ce
que ce qu'elle n'était absolument pas le
régime alimentaire des français
il ya deux siècles etc etc vous regarder
absolument n'importe quoi il a accès à
tout ce qu'il veut et vous regardez le
prix réel d' absolument n'importe quoi
une chemise une table une paire de
lunettes etc qui existait déjà il ya un
siècle et demi c'est quoi le prix réel
c'est le temps qu'il faut travailler
pour se le payer et bien ce prix réel a
été divisé par un facteur de 30 à 100
selon les objets que vous regardez un
paysan français il ya deux siècles
n'avait absolument pas les moyens en 20
ans de salaire de rembourser un logement
noé tout ce qu'il arrivait à faire
éventuellement je vous rappelle d'abord
qu'il dormait avec sa femme et ses
enfants dans le même lit donc les
parents copuler gaiement devant les
enfants
c'est des choses aujourd'hui qu'on voit
plus tellement enfin il faut quand même
vous rendre compte de ce que c'était que
la vie ordinaire
la vie ordinaire à 25 ans il est lui
dedans fin bon la vie ordinaire du
paysan français
il ya deux siècles ça n'a strictement
rien à voir avec les conditions du
smicard moderne strictement rien à voir
et la raison pour laquelle le smicard
rouspète il faut aller la chercher chez
tocqueville c'est consubstantiel à la
démocratie la démocratie disant que tout
le monde a les mêmes droits
si à l'arrivée il ya des gens qui ont
plus que vous c'est pas juste point faut
pas aller le chercher ailleurs
donc voici quelques-uns de nos esclaves
des temps modernes c'est un tout petit
sous ensembles évidemment parce que
l'armée de machines qui nous sert
aujourd'hui c'est des dizaines et des
dizaines de milliers de machines
différentes et avec leur nourriture
particulière qui soit dit en passant
nous économise du sol puisque les
esclaves anciens humains ou animaux ils
mangeaient du sol
il leur fallait une partie du sol pour
se nourrir et rester en vie et bien nos
esclaves des temps modernes
en plus ils ont la bonne idée de manger
du sous sol donc il nous laisse la
totalité du sol pour nous et ça ça
permet d'avoir quelques quelques
centaines pardon d'esclaves énergétique
à notre disposition
alors la nourriture de ces esclaves
énergétique aujourd'hui c'est
essentiellement ce qu'on appelle des
combustibles fossiles et dictionnaires
et bien fait c'est des résidus de
l'ancienne donc le charbon c'est des
résidus de végétaux le plan le
pétrole et le gaz s'était raidi du
plancton et ses combustibles fossiles
ont deux caractéristiques tout est en
anglais parce que je suis un feignant
temps en temps je fais des trucs en
anglais donc je change pas les
graphiques mais vous êtes des
anglicistes distinguer donc je pense que
vous comprendrez sans problème toutes
ces combustibles fossiles en deux
caractéristiques ce sont ce qu'on
appelle des énergies de stock
c'est à dire que le temps
caractéristiques de reconstitution du
stock est tellement élevé quelques
dizaines de millions à quelques
centaines de millions d'années que en
première approximation on peut
considérer que le stock est donnée une
fois pour toutes c'est ce qu'on appelle
les énergies de stock donc c'est le cas
du charbon du pétrole et du gaz et par
ailleurs comme c'est des résidus de vie
ancienne ça contient du carbone et quand
vous oxydé du carbone vous faites du co2
il ya pas tellement moyen de faire
autrement
donc les énergies dites fossiles ont
deux caractéristiques en commun leur
quantité est donnée une fois pour toutes
et quand on s'en sert ça fait du co2 je
vous disais tout à l'heure que
l'électricité était dans le monde pour
une large part faite au charbon vous
avez ici la décomposition de la
production électrique dans le monde 1
sur les dernières dizaines d'années ce
que vous voyez c'est que le charbon est
celle qui arrive en tête aujourd'hui et
c'est une énergie fossile
ensuite arrive le gaz qui est une
énergie fossile vous avez encore du
pétrole et voyez qu'en valeur absolue
c'est pas tellement différent de ce que
vous aviez il ya 40 ans c'est pas très
différent évidemment le reste est du
sras ajouté par dessus donc en part
relative ça a beaucoup baissé
mais il y en a à peu près la même
quantité et en ce qui concerne les nerfs
la première est de très loin ses
d'hydroélectricité voyez sur ce
graphique ce qui excite le journal et
dans ce qui excite le journal le solaire
vous ne le voyez même pas il existe un
île et laruns il est coincé entre le
vert et le rose et vous le voyez même
pas tellement c'est ridicule vous voyez
même pas d'accord ceci alors avec cela
voilà à quoi ressemble la répartition
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
dans le monde
ça c'est un graphique perso que j'ai
fait avec à la fois les consommations
énergétiques et la répartition grossière
au sein de certaines
au sein de certains usages des partants
au sein de certaines énergies des usages
est ce que vous voyez c'est que les
centrales électriques à charbon à
pétrole et à gaz mais surtout à charbon
représente plus d'un quart des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre mondiales toutes
activités confondues retenait que les
voitures particulières c'est 5%
les camions c'est 5% les bateaux c'est
3%
le transport aérien c'est 2% les
centrales électriques à charbon c'est
20% il ya un truc absolument
incontournable si on veut régler le
problème du changement climatique s'est
tué le charbon c'est juste non
négociable si on veut les deux degrés il
faut plus de centrales à charbon
j'aurais pas le temps pendant cet exposé
mais je peux vous dire que si on essaye
d'y arriver juste avec des panneaux
solaires et des éoliennes on n'est pas
rendu alors on fait du charbon et
derrière c'est aussi des éoliennes
et puis par ailleurs internet à
dématérialiser d'économies alors voici
le un petit graphique
vous savez un petit conseil pour votre
carrière professionnelle
quand vous poser une question ils
voulaient savoir si c'est vrai aller
chercher les séries statistiques et
faites les calculs en général ça relève
de la règle de trois et vous en aurez le
coeur net ne croyez jamais ce qui attend
le journal sans être allé vérifier par
vous même des fois vous aurez des
surprises
ici vous avez la quantité de co2 qui
correspond à l'utilisation d'une tonne
équivalent pétrole or la tonne
équivalent pétrole est un truc qui
normalement fait dresser les cheveux sur
la tête de veau prof de physique parce
que c'est absolument pas dans le système
international
c'est une unité que les énergéticiens
aime bien parce que ça permet de
caractériser les consommations des
individus avec des petits nombres la
consommation d'énergie d'un français en
tonnes équivalent pétrole 6 4 4 c'est
simple c'est plus simple que si
j'utilise des kilowattheures aux gens
des 60000 une tonne équivalent pétrole
fins et 50 mille ans domestique plutôt
une tonne équivalent pétrole c'est 11600
kilowattheure est en fait c'est le
contenu énergétique libéré par la
combustion d'une tonne de pétrole de
qualité moyenne
ouf donc on utilise souvent ce genre
d'unité et évidemment quand c'est du
pétrole
une tonne équivalent pétrole c'est une
tonne de pétrole un égal ans c'est quand
même simple
pulls et des équivalences donc ici vous
avez la quantité de co2 émise par tonne
équivalent pétrole d'énergie utilisée
dans le monde toutes les énergies
confondues est pas ce que vous voyez
c'est que sur un siècle et demi cette
quantité varie assez peu l'ordre de
grandeur reste toujours le même on était
à deux on est monté à 3 on est
redescendu à deux et demi est ce que
vous voyez surtout c'est que depuis 2000
c'est à dire depuis le début de toutes
les révolutions qui enchante les
journalistes et certains ingénieurs et
bien cette grandeur ne varie pas donc
est ce qu'internet a dématérialisé
l'économie sofa absolument pas voyez que
on était à 2,5 tonnes tonnes de co2 par
tonne équivalent pétrole en 2000
c'est pas parce que internet est apparu
que tout d'un coup cette grandeur a
varié toujours la même et depuis la
révolution des énergies renouvelables et
bien cette grandeur n'a pas varié non
plus donc les deux grandes révolutions
le numérique et les énergies
renouvelables qui ont commencé à se
déployer depuis le début des années 2000
pour le moment n'ont pas eu le moindre
effet sur la quantité de co2 par tonne
équivalent pétrole
elles n'ont pas plus eu d'effet je vous
montre pas aujourd'hui sur ce qu'on
appelle l'efficacité énergétique de
l'économie
c'est dire que la quantité d'énergie
qu'il faut utiliser pour faire 1 euros
de pib n'a strictement est strictement
la même aujourd'hui que en 2000
strictement la même toujours dans les
idées reçues vous avez ici
l'augmentation reflète enfin
l'augmentation de chacune d énergie
qu'on utilise dans le monde entre 2000
et 2014
donc je fais la différence entre la
quantité qu'on utilise en 2014 et la
quantité qu'on utilise en 2000 puis je
regarde ce que ça vaut 2014
on utilise 1500 millions dont 1,5
milliard tonnes équivalent pétrole de
charbon en plus dans le monde qu'en 2008
toutes les autres bars solistes de la
même manière et bien ce que vous voyez
sur ce graphique c'est que sur la
période de ville 2014
le charbon a augmenté 35 fois plus que
le solaire est dix fois plus que
l'éolien donc ce qui s'est vraiment
passé dans le monde sur cette période
c'est pas la révolution urinaires c'est
le boom du charbon c'est ça qui s'est
vraiment passé normande
à ce stade retenait un certain nombre
pardon à ce stade je vais continuer sur
la distinction entre deux termes qu'on
trouve parfois dans monde énergétique
qui sont primaires et finale je vous
avais dit que je vous parlais de la loi
de conservation la voix si vous
connaissez la loi de conservation
évidemment normalement vous la
connaissez mieux que moi j'applique la
loi de conservation à l'humanité
l'application de la loi de conservation
de l'énergie à l'humanité vous dis ceci
l'homme ne peut rien faire d'autre que
d' exploiter à son profit une source
d'énergie qui existe déjà dans
l'environnement
l'homme ne peut rien faire d'autre que
d' exploiter à son profit une source
d'énergie qui existe déjà dans
l'environnement la production d'énergie
termes que vous trouvez parfois dans les
journaux est un terme impropre
vous ne savez pas produire de l'énergie
vous savez l'extraire et la transformer
les produire de l'énergie
ça n'existe pas de convention
économiques font que toutes les énergies
primaires sont gratuites
le pétrole est gratuit le charbon est
gratuit le vent est gratuit le soleil
est gratuit le gaz est gratuit le radium
et gratuit toutes ces énergies existe
dans l'environnement jeu des biens
existent sans que vous ayez à payer le
moindre centime vous et moi n'avons
jamais payé le moindre centime pour que
le pétrole existe ce qu'il faut payer
c'est les gens qui vont le chercher et
les gens qui sont assis dessus mais ça
c'est pas la formation du pétrole c'est
un problème de bons hommes n'auraient pu
décider que le pétrole appartenait à
tout le monde donc les énergies
primaires sont tout tout tout gratuite
par convention du coup ce qu'on paye
quand on paye de l'énergie c'est
uniquement des revenus humain qui
correspondent soit du travail soient
adhérentes pour extraire et transformer
cette énergie
dit autrement le coût de l'énergie ne
représente n'est que la contrepartie de
la facilité à accéder et à transformer
l'énergie
c'est ça le coût de l'énergie c'est la
contrepartie de la facilité qu'on a à y
accéder et à la transformer de ce fait
plus une énergie et présente sous forme
diffuse et non
pilotable plus il faut de travail pour
la concentrer et la mettre à disposition
et plus ça vaudra cher
la quantité qui en a dans
l'environnement n'est pas le sujet on
s'en fout ce qui compte c'est sa
concentration le rayonnement à 3 kelvin
de l'univers représente une quantité
considérable d'énergie bien plus
considérables que le rayonnement solaire
qui arrivent sur terre est bien plus
considérables que les stocks de pétrole
que nous avons sur terre vous et moi
n'en ferons jamais rien de toute notre
vie donc ce qui va compter c'est la
nature de l'énergie et en particulier
son degré de concentration et de ce
point de vue le pétrole représente
l'optimum de ce que l'humanité utilisera
pendant sa vie quand vous êtes passé des
nerfs parce que je vous rappelle que ces
salles historiques des hommes c'est
d'abord les nerfs c'est d'abord le bois
d'abord le soleil d'abord le vent qui a
fait avancer les premiers bateaux et
d'abord la traction animale tout ça est
parfait d'abord les esclaves tout ça est
parfaitement renouvelables donc quand on
est passé des nerfs au charbon on a
gagné un cran en termes de facilité
d'accès à des stocks
quand on est passé du charbon au pétrole
on a encore gagné un cran et depuis le
pétrole on descend le gaz c'est moins
pratique le pétrole le nucléaire c'est
moins pratique que le gaz et les nerfs
moderne c'est encore moins pratique que
le nucléaire
à chaque fois vous perdez un cran et la
traduction économique c'est qu'à chaque
fois où vous devez engager beaucoup plus
de capitaux pour arriver au même
résultat
c'est ça la traduction économique alors
la traduction un peu plus détaillée de
ce que je viens de vous dire elle est là
donc vous avez donc des sources
d'énergie primaire dans l'environnement
c'est l'énergie qui existent déjà donc
des trucs qui brûlent des trucs qui
tombe et ses champs les machines ne
mange pas d'énergie primaire elles
savent pas faire ça dans ce qu'elles
vont manger c'est de l'énergie finale
des carburants raffinés du gaz raffiné
du gaz purifiée par dont les déficits et
s'est passé de l'énergie primaire à
l'énergie finale c'est ce qu'on a c'est
l'objet du système énergétique
donc ce qu'on va trouver dans le système
énergétique c'est tout ce qui permet de
passer du primaire au final à nouveau la
loi de conservation intervient
vous avez toujours autant ou moins
d'énergie finale que vous aviez
d'énergie primaire et entre les deux
vous avez éventuellement ce qu'on
appelle des pertes
par exemple quand vous transformez de la
chaleur en électricité vous avez des
pertes ce qu'arnaud vous dit que le
rendement est plafonnée
les pertes standard des centrales
thermiques dans le monde ces deux tiers
que ce soit du charbon et du nucléaire
ne change strictement rien à faire c'est
pareil et enfin l'énergie vous allez pas
en disposer
exactement la machine vous n'allez pas
lui donner du pétrole juste pour plaisir
de lui donner du pétrole ce qui vous
intéresse et d'avoir un service derrière
on utilise parfois le terme d'énergie
utile pour qualifier l'énergie contenue
dans le service lui même quand vous
mettez de l'essence dans votre voiture
c'est de l'énergie finale quand vous
avez du mouvement avec votre voiture
c'est de l'énergie utile entre les deux
avec un moteur à essence vous perdez
encore 80% 70 le système énergétique son
amélioration est une affaire
d'ingénieurs c'est pour ça que tous les
politiques adorent parler du système
énergétique
ça permet d'emmerdés une sous fraction
de la population tout à fait minime en
faisant croire à tout le reste de la
population que ça va changer sa vie en
tout en la laissant à 6 dans son canapé
donc les politiques adore s'occuper du
système énergétique
il adore aussi s'occuper de la partie
ingénieurs de l'efficacité énergétique
donc dit autrement s'il s'agit de faire
des voitures qui consomment deux fois
moins tout en étant disponible au même
prix pour les consommateurs finals
il adore ça remet ici encore un poème
d'ingénieurs ce que les politiques des
tests
c'est dire à la population qu'elle va
faire des économies d'énergie en
divisant sa surface habitable par deux
ça il n'aime pas du tout or dans les
économies d'énergie
vous en avez qui ne relèvent que d'une
efficacité accrue des processus et vous
en avez qui relèvent de ce qu'on appelle
la sobriété
c'est à dire que délibérément les gens
acceptent de consommer moins dans les
deux cas de figure vous avez besoin de
moins d'énergie dans le premier vous
emmerder juste les ingénieurs dans le
deuxième vous emmerder tout le monde
donc en démocratie on privilégiera
toujours la première catégorie
jamais la seconde et tous les
dispositifs économiques qui vise à
favoriser la sobriété la fiscalité et la
réglementation etc sont toujours des
trucs que les politiques sont les
premiers à ne pas aimer sauf si ça
emmerde une sous catégorie très précise
de la population
si je parle d'énergie finale voilà à
quoi ça ressemble dans le monde
donc voilà l'énergie finale pas
vecteur primaire par énergie primaire
dont elle est issue est ce que vous
voyez c'est que les hydrocarbures font
80% du total donc on est massivement
dépendant des hydrocarbures et le
pétrole est dominant dans cet ensemble
vous avez sûrement entendu que la france
est un pays tout nucléaire qui n'a
jamais entendu que la france est un pays
tout nucléaire
donc vous lisez le journal de temps en
temps c'est bien bon donc la france est
un pays tout nucléaire
vous avez ici la consommation d'énergie
finale en france par catégorie de
secteurs de consommation donc selon là
où est la machine qui mangent l'énergie
eh bien ça s'appelle résidentiel la
machine est chez vous percière la
machine et sur vos lieux de travail sauf
les processus industriels industrie
c'est la machine relève d'un processus
industriel
agriculture la machine et dans un champ
etc vous avez graduée en milliards de
kilowattheures par an sur l'échelle
verticale et maintenant tout ce que je
cercle bien des hydrocarbures fonte des
combustibles fossiles et je vous repose
la question est ce que la france est un
pays tout nucléaire
seul à pouvoir se discuter
d'accord avec points et sur le plan
économique
ça se discute encore plus alors ce
graphique a été fait à l'époque où le
baril valait 100 dollars mais enfin mon
pronostic c'est que il va finir par y
revenir
dont vous avez le pétrole qui représente
les deux tiers du co2 français et
quelques dizaines de milliards de
dollars d'importations parents vous avez
le gaz qui représente plus de 10
milliards d'euros d'importations parents
et un quart de notre co2 vous avez
encore du charbon et vous avez
effectivement du nucléaire qui selon les
années représentent 0,5 à 1 milliard
d'uranium à porter qui fait pas de co2
donc on peut discuter du fait que ce
soit notre premier problème
en fait on peut discuter pour d'autres
raisons aussi je vous disais tout à
l'heure l'énergie à transformer vos 10
alors là je vais y revenir avec quelque
chose d'assez fondamentale qui est que
si aujourd'hui vous vivez dans un monde
d'employés de bureau habitant en ville
c'est à cause de l'énergie vous avez ici
la structure de l'emploi en france sur
les deux derniers siècles
il ya deux siècles comme vous pouvez le
voir l'essentiel de la population active
est au chant en de bon c'est à dire
qu'elle est occupée à faire pousser des
patates et comme c'est les deux tiers de
la population active
la règle de trois vous dit que la
productivité d'un agriculteur
époque là est suffisante pour qu'il
arrive à se nourrir lui +0 5 personnes
qui fait autre chose
d'accord les deux tiers des actifs sont
dans les champs aujourd'hui pour info
l'agriculteur arrive à se nourrir lui
plus 50 personnes qui font autre chose
évidemment c'est pas l'agriculteur tous
coup tout court c'est l'agriculteur plus
son tracteur sa moissonneuse batteuse
ces silos les trains de céréales etc
vous avez donc une population agricole
qui est l'essentiel de la population
active
ah oui que cette population agricole
elle augmente pendant quelques dizaines
d'années à partir du début de cette
série et ceci correspond à cela c'est à
dire que la productivité d'un
agriculteur à cette époque là à bouge
pas beaucoup d'une année sur l'autre par
contre les surfaces agricoles augmente
en france puisque le minimum forestier
ses terres le maximum de déforestation
en france a été atteint en 1850 à
l'époque 15 % du territoire seulement
étaient couverts de forêts l'europe part
entamé son processus de déforestation
dans les années 1700 miné en 1850 et
puis vous voyez qu'après la population
celui à diminuer est ce que ça veut dire
qu'il ya moins de surfaces non ça veut
juste dire qu'il ya moins d'agriculteurs
parce que leur productivité augmente et
leur productivité augmente parce grâce à
l'énergie
on commence à leur fournir en quantité
croissante des outils de plus en plus
efficaces pour cultiver les socs de
charrues qui sont lieu des colliers très
des endroits pour entreposer qui sont
mieux et c'est tout ça et fabriqués par
l'industrie descente
et puis après la guerre l'industrie va
exploser en fournissant aux agriculteurs
engrais de synthèse phytosanitaires et
tracteurs tout ça par exemple a
multiplié par 8 la productivité à
l'hectare du blé en france 40 ont donc
je mets des machines dans les champs et
partout ailleurs
et à ce moment à surface identique et à
production croissante je diminue très
fortement la quantité d'agriculteurs
nécessaire mais vous voyez que dans le
même temps la population active dans les
autres secteurs augmente pourquoi parce
qu'avec l'énergie croissante j'ai les
moyens d'extraire en quantité croissante
de la terre des minerais de toutes
natures et d'en faire des objets de
toute nature qu'il faut fabriquer et
vendre et accessoirement financer c'est
le début de l'industrie c'est à dire
c'est le début des machines et comme je
le disais tout à l'heure une machine et
un emploi puisqu'il faut piloter la
machine et donc j'ai de plus en plus de
machines elles ont besoin de plus en
plus de gens dans l'industrie une fois
que les produits sortent de la porte de
lusine folle et distribué faut les
vendre
il faut les financer faut compter faut
les transporter tout ça va s'appeler des
services et qu'il faut apprendre aux
gens à se servir des machines etc tout
ça va s'appeler les services les
services n'ont jamais été autre chose
que quelque chose d'assez sur la couche
physique sous jacente qui s'appelle
l'industrie viry l'industrie il ya plus
de services virez l'industrie et la
construction vous avez plus dans fille
vous avez plus d'ordinateur vous n'avez
plus les bancs vous avez pu les chaises
vous avez plus les moyens de transport
qui vous permettent de venir ici il ya
plus l'école des ponts d'accord donc les
services ne sont pas détachés de
l'industrie et ils peuvent vivre leur
vie de manière autonome
ça n'existe pas les services c'est une
exploitation de la couche physique sous
jacente qui est dans l'industrie
et puis arrive les chocs pétroliers
alors qu'est ce qui se passe au moment
des chocs pétroliers
la quantité d'énergie disponible par
personne s'arrête de croître en occident
mais la taille unitaire des machines
elles elles continuent d'augmenter
j'ai pas plus d'énergie par personne
mais une taille unitaire de machines qui
augmente traduction logique
j'ai besoin de moins en moins de gens
pour piloter ces machines donc la
quantité induit la production
industrielle après 74 continue
d'augmenter mais elle est faite par des
machines qui dont la taille va se mettre
à augmenter plus vite que la production
globale et donc l'emploi dans
l'industrie va se mettre à baisser et ce
phénomène s'observe partout dans les
pays industrialisés absolument partout
il n'empêche que la production
industrielle continue d'augmenter et
donc les services que j'ai à la suite
continue d'augmenter aussi mais tout ça
n'est plus suffisant à partir des chocs
pétroliers et je vois aussi apparaître
une catégorie qui n'existait pas avant
c'est à dire les gens à qui je n'ai rien
j'ai pas de machine à donner à piloter
dit autrement je suis désormais
tellement productif par actif à cause de
toutes ces machines
après les chocs pétroliers et le monde
commence déjà à me mettre un peu à
l'étroit et j'ai pu les moyens de donner
un emploi c'est à dire
pilotage de machines à chaque personne
qui a envie de poser le chômage était de
3% 2 à 3% de la population active avant
les chocs pétroliers
il y est évidemment jamais revenu alors
ça c'est la version dynamique je vais
vous en donner une version statique tout
de suite vous avez ici un nuage de
points qui est fait avec pour chaque
pays qui représentaient sur ce nuage
donc il doit y avoir je pourquoi 150
pays là dedans en abscisse la quantité
d'énergie consommée par personne et en
ordonnée la fraction de la population
active qui travaillent dans
l'agriculture
et tout ça concerne l'année 2011 et vous
voyez que en gros vous avez une relation
en 1 / x dis moi combien y'a d'énergie
par personne dans ton pays je te dirai
quel est la fraction d'agriculteurs
marche extrêmement bien
j'ai donc mis des machines à la place
des agriculteurs donc j'ai vidé les
campagnes j'ai créé des industries et
des services tout ça se passe dans les
villes les services en particulier parce
que les services inclus énormément
d'échangés les échanges sont plus
efficaces quand les gens sont assez par
mètre carré que vous avez des gens par
mètre carré plus la densité des changes
est importante et donc plus les services
sont efficaces vous avez un petit stand
où les villes parce qu'en mettant une
voiture par personne encore de l'énergie
vous avez les moyens en une heure de
temps de parcourir une distance plus
grande que si vous êtes à pied donc vous
pouvez conserver le tissu des changes
qui est le fait de la ville tout en les
talents et nous avons donc créé dans
tous les pays occidentaux je dis bien
tous les pays occidentaux le même
paysage le même aménagement du
territoire des campagnes vidéo profite
des tracteurs et des gens qui se mettent
à bosser dans l'industrie et les
services concentrés dans les villes
l'aménagement du territoire c'est de
l'industrie la structure sociale c'est
de l'industrie c'est de l'énergie par
dont l'aménagement c'est de l'énergie et
la structure sociale c'est de l'énergie
et la macroéconomie c'est de l'énergie
aussi donc je vous fais je vais vous
dire tout de suite que ce que va vous
raconter votre prof d'éco d'avis si vous
en avez un je suis désolé je vais oser
c'est bullshit et je vous le dis tout de
suite vous avez ici la représentation
conventionnelle dans l'économie que j'ai
apprise à l'école de la manière dont le
système se présente donc vous avez du
capital et du travail comme facteur de
production et puis à la sortie vous avez
une production et si la production flag
à douille et qu'on n'arrive pas à payer
les retraites
eh bien on botte le cul des gens qui ne
travaillent pas donc on augmente l'offre
de travail on baisse le smic etc
ah et on dit aux banquiers d'arrêter de
jouer au casino avec leur pognon est de
financer l'économie réelle et donc le
pib par tête d'accor manque de pot ça
marche pas c'est ce qu'on essaye de
faire partout dans les pays occidentaux
depuis 2007 c'est à dire depuis le
moment où l'approvisionnement
énergétique de l' ocde est passé par un
maximum sa de marche nulle part le pib
ne repart pas et quand il repart c'est
que des bulles spéculatives qui est en
train de se passer en ce moment avec une
inflation de dettes absolument colossal
et la seule question c'est de savoir
quand sera le prochain krach et tout ça
ne marche pas tout simplement parce que
c'est pas la bonne représentation du
système la bonne représentation du
système
elle est très simple la voici qu'est ce
que c'est que l'économie c'est une
machine à transformer des ressources
mettez une usine à faire des bouteilles
en verre au lieu du vide intersidéral
sans approvisionnement en gaz et sans
approvisionnement en sable elle fait pas
de bouteilles en verre mettez un bateau
de pêche sur la mer sans poissons à
pêcher et sans gasoil dans la cuve du
bateau vous pêchez rien du tout donc ce
qu'il faut pour que l'économie
fonctionne c'est que vous ayez des
ressources à transformer et notre
système productif n'est qu'une immense
machine à transformer des ressources
tout ce que vous avez dans cette salle
tout ce que vous verrez du début de la
journée à la fin tout ce que vous verrez
de votre naissance à votre mort ça n'est
rien d'autre que des ressources
naturelles transformer ou non par notre
activité
si rien d'autre que ça sauf que il ya
deux siècles ya des petits malins à
juste titre à l'époque qui ont dit leurs
ressources s'en occupe pas c'est gratuit
pourquoi est ce qu'ils ont dit ça parce
qu'il ya deux siècles ya moins d'un
milliard de bonshommes la productivité
par personne et 50 à 100 fois inférieure
à ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui
donc le stock est immense au regard de
nos possibilités de transformation d'une
petite partie du stock et vous savez que
si le stock est infini en première
approximation deltastock nuls et on va
quand même pas s'emmerder à trimballer
partout comme le savant cosinus d égal
zéro dans nos équations donc on oublie
stocks deux siècles après les ordres de
grandeur ont changé d'un facteur 10 100
1000 1 million parfois on oublie
toujours le stock c'est emmerdant parce
que la delta stocks et plus du tout nul
du tout du tout du tout du tout
et dans la transformation des ressources
notre pauvre carcasse compte points
pendant que les machines qu'ils mangent
de l'énergie compte pour 200 c'est le
rapport de 20 à 200 dont je vous parlais
tout à l'heure
alors une fois vous avez cette
représentation avec les mains tout
devient très clair si vous avez pas
assez d'énergie vous aurait pas assez de
production même si les banquiers sont
sympa même si les gens se lèvent le
matin et même si vous avez plein de
ressources aussi con que ça très
accessoirement si vous manquez de
ressources
vous aurez aussi un problème sur la
production donc ça c'est une théorie
très très simple et vous allez voir que
alcool très très bien avec les données
qui s'observe vous avez ici le pib
mondial reconstitué depuis l'an zéro
alors pendant mille ans pas de promesses
électorales sur la croissance affaire il
n'y a pas de croissance
ça simplifie quand même c'est le
problème pas besoin de promettre la lune
puisque personne ne s'attend à voir la
ville jusqu'au début de la révolution
industrielle
il y en a m'enfin faut un microscope
avec l'échelle de cette courbe pour
l'avoir 0.9 vraiment pas grand chose
donc aller en première approximation il
ya toujours pas de croissance
et puis arrive les combustibles fossiles
et crac 3% par an est merveilleux les
merveilleux à disneyland juste à côté
d'ici ils vont même pas pareil
malgré tout les magiciens il suit des
dessins animés de disney 3% en
merveilleux en question qui d'entre vous
est prêt à parier la totalité de ses
économies sur le fait que ça va durer
encore quelques dizaines d'années
je suis étonné que les journalistes
posent jamais cette question aux
politiques quand ils les interviewe
quand il leur dit vous savez voilà ce
que je vais obtenir premier truc que je
lui dirai c'est ce que vous êtes prêt à
parier votre pognon là dessus bon
il manque de malice vous voyez donc
début des combustibles fossiles + 3 %
par an alors ça marche
de cette manière mais ça marche d'une
autre manière vous avez ici depuis 1965
envers la variation de la quantité
annuelle d'énergie consommée dans le
monde en bleu la variation du pib
mondial de moyens je te donne l'autre et
réciproquement
awake de temps en temps les deux
s'écarte un tout petit peu et c'est
notamment le cas là et ben si vous
regardez attentivement cette courbe les
autres fois où ça s'est produit en
général ça apprécié n'aide pas beaucoup
une plongée vers le bas parce qu une des
manières de faire du pib dématérialisé
c'est-à-dire sans énergie c'est de faire
des bulles spéculatives
quand le prix de l'immobilier double ça
vous augmente mécaniquement le pib parce
que ça vous augmente la production de
crédit ça vous augmente les commissions
d'agent ça vous augmente les impôts
locaux au moment des transactions ça
vous augmente au tas de trucs comme ça
vous n'avez pas un kilowattheures
d'énergie en plus qu'ils soient
mobilisés par contre ça vous créer des
bulles spéculatives et ça vous créez de
la dette
et ça c'est des équilibres instables et
à un moment ça finit par dégonfler
rapidement c'est très exactement ce qui
se constate depuis 2007
depuis 2007 la dette fédérale des états
unis à doubler quasiment la dette
publique anglaise a doublé enfin je veux
dire tous les pays très fortement
financiarisé ont vu leur dette exploser
et sauf a inventé la dette perpétuelle à
un moment faudra bien dire qu'on la
rembourse pas les grecs ils ont commencé
à s'y coller c'est 1% du pib européen
quand ça sera les suivants ça fait un
peu plus mal
donc c'est des processus qui sont
instables donc y aura une correction
vers le bas à un moment c'est absolument
évident pour moi et voilà le meilleur
modèle macroéconomique du monde
s'appelle une droite voyez j'ai mis en
abscisse je les fais candidement ça
c'est un graphique que j'ai fait pour la
première fois il ya cinq ans je
m'attendais pas du tout à trouver ça que
j'ai vraiment candidement pris la
quantité d'énergie consommée dans le
monde depuis 65 en ordonner j'ai mis le
pays des déflatés dans le monde depuis
2000 65 je suis tombé là dessus donc le
meilleur modèle macroéconomique dans le
monde
ça s'appelle une droite d'accord donne
moi l'énergie je te donnerai le pib
voilà donc ce que je vous raconte depuis
cinquante minutes je vais un peu
accéléré maintenant je suis désolé
on a des stocks de ressources naturelles
de toute nature dont des stocks de
combustible fossile tout ça est gratuit
la totalité est gratuit je vous rappelle
que par convention toutes les ressources
naturelles sont gratuites d'eau ça brûle
et ça nous permet d'avoir les moteurs et
la chimie c'est à dire que ça accélère
par transformation d autres sources
la totalité des biens transformer qu'on
peut avoir notre disposition
là dessus on a bâti une structure
sociale que chacun quand ils descendent
dans la rue considère acquise pour
l'éternité qui est la structure actuelle
les métiers la croissance à gogo les
loisirs les machins et c'est tout ça
c'est de l'énergie est la contrepartie
économique de ce truc là s'appelle le
pib je vous rappelle que le pib c'est la
transformation - le pib c'est un
empilement de ce qu'on appelle les
valeur ajoutée et une valeur ajoutée
vous avez ça chez un agent économique
quand vous avez de la transformation
entre ce qui rendait ce qui sort ce qui
sort normalement si vous fait pas
faillite vaut plus cher puisqu'il rentre
et la différence entre les deux
s'appelle la valeur ajoutée
deux questions la première dont on vous
a parlé valérie masson delmotte
combien de temps est-ce qu'on peut jouer
à ce petit jeu là sans que le système
climatique non gendre une
déstabilisation tels que ça perturbera
le processus qui en est à l'origine
dit autrement nous donc ça contractera
la taille de l'humanité l'espérance de
vie et ses questions à
question b que je rajoute combien de
temps est-ce qu'on peut jouer à ce petit
jeu là avec les stocks donnés une fois
pour toutes qui sont à notre disposition
pour des raisons qui tiennent à la
manière dont fonctionnent les médias j'y
reviendrai au moment des questions parce
que j'ai pas me lancer là dedans tout de
suite il se trouve que le premier sujet
celui du bas est déjà en train
d'appliquer ses effets depuis les chocs
pétroliers sans qu'on s'en rende compte
alors que le sujet duo commence
seulement à appliquer ses effets
maintenant sans qu'on s'en rende compte
aussi du reste parce que pour moi le
printemps arabe est d'ailleurs trouve
ses racines pour partie dans un problème
de changement climatique là aussi je
reviendrai s'il ya des questions donc
juste on comprend pas mais c'est mais
c'est ça les deux questions alors je
vais commencer par celle du vent je vous
rappelle que quand on tape dans un stock
de départ qui est donnée une fois pour
toutes
les maths interdisent que l'extraction
annuel en provenance de ce stock soit
indéfiniment croissante
ça vous êtes d'accord avec moi les maths
interdisent même que l'extraction annuel
en provenance de ce stock sont
indéfiniment constante et en fait il ya
un théorème je crois que c'est une
variante du théorème de rôle enfin chez
elle démontrait mais je m'en rappelle
plus de son nom qui vous dit que si vous
tapez dans un stock de départ qui est
donnée une fois pour toute et bien
l'extraction annuel de ce stock est
nécessairement nul à moins d'un fini nul
à + l'infini et passe par un maximum
entre les deux l'extraction cumulé
c'est-à-dire l'intégrale de la courbe
est au plus la valeur du stock de départ
donc quand vous tapez dans un stock de
départ qui est donnée une fois pour
toutes
vous aurez à pic à l'extraction annuel
c'est pas de l'idéologie c'est les maths
et là aussi toute théorie politique ou
sociale qui viole un théorème de maths
fera faillite
exactement de la même manière que ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure pour l'autre
conservation il règle de trois donc vous
aurez où il est déjà passé un pic à
l'extraction annuel du minerai de cuivre
de la bauxite des diamants du platine de
l'or du ruthénium du tout ce que vous
voulez des oxydes de bidouille sommes
divers et variés et évidemment du
pétrole du gaz du charbon de l'uranium
just name it vous aurez un pic tout tout
tout passera par un pic en ce qui
concerne le pétrole la seule question
c'est est ce qu'il est déjà passé ou
est-ce qu'il est devant nous et la
réponse courte si on est dessus mondiale
est là alors en fait c'est pas un pic
exact c'est plutôt le mont aiguille
c'est un plateau zigzaguant je vais vous
montrer alors vous savez quand on est au
pic la dérouillée s'annulent avant le
pic la dérive est positive
aupic la dérive et ça dure regardons la
dérive et vous avez ici la dérive et en
ce qui concerne l'extraction mondiale de
pétrole
ou plus exactement la variation lycée
sur dix ans de l'extraction de pétrole
dans le monde
à l'époque où nous disposions d'une
technologie qui ferait honte aux gens
qui sortent de cette école est bien la
croissance de la production mondiale de
pétrole était de 15%
parent puis sont venues des ingénieurs
des ponts un peu plus qualifiés et la
croissance est descendu à 10 % par an
puis sont venues des ingénieurs des
ponts et du reste allez je peux être
sage être sympa encore plus qualifiés et
c'est descendu à 5 puis sont venues des
ingénieurs extrêmement qualifiés et
l'aide de la réserve fédérale américaine
et on n'est pas loin de zéro à chaque
fois
la nouvelle technologie n'a pas été un
moyen de faire mieux ça a été une
réponse à la baisse
c'est comme ça que ça s'est passé c'est
pas de gaîté de coeur que les pétroliers
ont augmenté par un facteur 6 ou 5 leurs
investissements sur les huit dernières
années dans l'amont pétrolier c'est
juste parce que c'est devenu nécessaire
pour aller chercher du pétrole s'il
pouvait dépenser beaucoup moins ils
seraient très contents et dépenser
beaucoup moins ça veut dire en
particulier qui qu'on serait pas c'est
très compliqué il faut savoir que gaz et
pétrole de roche-mère ce qu'on appelle
dans la presse gaz et pétrole de schiste
ont connu depuis deux siècles
la première exploitation commerciale de
gaz aux etats unis c'était du gaz de
schiste à fredonia sur la côte est
en 1826 si ma mémoire est bonne 1124
confond toujours avec la découverte de
l'effet de serre mais en gros c'est dans
ces années là donc c'est quelque chose
qui est très ancien et le gaz de schiste
et back to all of you tube
c'est à dire que j'exploite est un truc
qui était beaucoup plus commode que les
gaz et pétrole de roche-mère qui
s'appelle les gisements conventionnels
puis en a de moins en moins donc je me
mets à retaper dans des trucs que je
connaissais mais qui sont de moins bonne
qualité
c'est ça le processus des gaz et
pétroles de schiste voilà à quoi
ressemble la production mondiale de ce
qu'on appelle les liquides je vais pas
m'éterniser sur la définition c'est pas
juste du pétrole voilà où nous sommes
donc bon y'a quoi la question que tout
le monde se pose c'est combien ça va
coûter ma réponse est on s'en fout c'est
pas la question
d'abord c'est pas la question parce que
personne n'est capable de faire un
pronostic
vous avez ici en là aussi un truc auquel
je vous conseille de vous livrer toute
votre carrière durant c'est quand des
gens font des pronostics depuis vingt
ans regarder sur les vingt dernières
années comment est-ce que leurs
pronostics des années successives se
compare à ce qui s'est vraiment passé
et quand vous avez ce genre de trucs
arrêtez de les écouter donc en rouge
ce que vous avez c'est ce qu'a vraiment
donné le prix du baril de pétrole sur
lesquels les marchés
prix du baril de pétrole depuis 1985 et
les tous les traits de couleurs c'est
les pronostics qui ont été faits par
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie sur
ce que sur la manière dont devait
évoluer le prix du pétrole
bon bah moi si j'ai un responsable
marketing dans ma boîte qui me fait ce
genre de prévisions sur mes ventes sur
les prix je peux vous dire que je le
fois la porte tout de suite
deuxième raison pour laquelle le prix on
s'en fout c'est qu'à pas de lien entre
le prix et les quantités à mais mon prof
d'économie non n'y a pas de lien entre
les prix les quantités
il n'y a pas de lien entre le prix et la
quantité
vous savez toujours entendus en économie
s'il y en a plus c'est moins cher et
derrière ça marche des fois des fois ça
marche pas donc ce n'est pas une loi
vous savez qu'une loi n'est plus une loi
si elle a au moins une exception est
bien le rapport entre les prix et les
volumes souffre énormément d'exception
dans le monde et le pétrole en étude
remarquable entre 1920 et 1973
le volume de pétrole consommé dans le
monde a été multiplié par plus de 20 le
prix est resté constant y a pas vraiment
d élasticité prix volume après les chocs
pétroliers pendant une grosse dizaine
d'années le prix a fait n'importe quoi
avec un volume qui est resté quasi
constant puis de nouveau le prix s'est
mis à osciller autour de 30 dollars
constants le baril alors que la quantité
consommée augmentait de 25 % puis depuis
le début des années 2000 la quantité
consommée varie très peu avec un prix
qui fait absolument n'importe quoi en
fait la seule chose là aussi j'ai rien
voici à des questions qu'on est capable
de théoriser à mon avis en ce qui
concerne le pétrole c'est que quand la
quantité disponible devient contrainte
le prix devient aussillon donc si on
laisse faire le marché pour que les gens
économisent du pétrole en période de
pétrole contre 1 vous n'aurez pas le
signal prix parce que le pétrole le prix
fera n'importe quoi mon travail décent
bras et mon travail décent etc et je
fais partie des gens qui n'ont jamais
affirmé que quand le pétrole devient
vrai contraint son prix allait augmenter
indéfiniment
je n'y ai jamais cru et j'ai toujours
cru que le prix deviendraient aussi ce
qui est en train de se passer en ce
moment avec le baril car descend à 40
dollars parfaitement normal pour moi
puis ça va remonter et redescendre
y a pas plus de lien entre le prix du
pétrole et le pib mondial s'il y avait
un lien entre les deux si je fais un
graphique en mettant en abscisse le prix
du baril de pétrole et en ordonnée le
pib mondial est bien mais nuages de
points devrait s'organiser le long de
quelque chose qui ressemble à une
hyperbole donc quand le baril augmente
pib baisse et quand le baril diminue le
pib augmente
oui c'est pas du tout ce qui se passe le
pib peut augmenter avec un prix du
pétrole qui baissent il peut augmenter
avec un prix du pétrole qui monte il
peut augmenter avec un prix du pétrole
qui baissent il peut augmenter avec un
prix du pétrole qui monte il peut
augmenter avec un prix du pétrole qui
baisse il n'y a aucun lien entre le pib
mondial et peu du pétrole aucun aucun
c'est un jeu à somme nulle
si le prix du pétrole augmente et les
producteurs s'en mettre plein les poches
et les consommateurs souffrent points et
après le qatar nous achète le psg les
galeries farfouille est et tout va bien
mais pas lyon par contre pour les
importateurs
là ça fait une petite différence les
importateurs évidemment payent plus cher
quand le pétrole vaut plus cher ce qui
compte en ce qui concerne le pétrole à
nouveau
c'est le volume vous avez ici un
graphique qui vous donne depuis 1965 en
fait c'est 1968 parce que c'est une
moyenne glissante sur trois ans la
variation de la production mondiale de
pétrole donc pas le prix à la production
en rouge et la variation du pib par
personne en bleu est bien ce que vous
constatez c'est que depuis les chocs
pétroliers c'est à dire depuis le moment
où le pétrole est devenu contraint les
chocs pétroliers c'est le moment où la
production mondiale s'arrête de croître
de 10% par an et passe à 1 % par an de
croissance 2005 c'est le moment où elles
passent de 1 % par an de croissance à 0
0 2005 la production mondiale de pétrole
n'augmente plus nonobstant le miracle du
pétrole de schiste américain donc ça
veut dire que ça monte aux états unis ça
descend partout ailleurs eh bien vous
voyez que depuis cette époque là le pib
par personne évolué exactement comme la
production en volume de pétrole et non
seulement il évolue comme elle mais il
est vu quand même avec retard vous voyez
que le rouge précède le bleu dans ses
courbes ce qui est une manière de dire
qu'on ne consomme pas plus de pétrole
parce qu'à de la croissance c'est parce
qu'on a plus de pétrole qui est de la
croissance
et on en revient à mon petit graphique
de tout à l'heure et la raison à cela
est très simple le pétrole c'est les
échanges les
changeons indispensable de l'activité
économique vous n'avez plus aujourd'hui
un acteur économique qui assure la
totalité des transformation et la
commercialisation sans déplacement un
acteur économique n'est que le maillon
d'une vaste chaîne entre les entre les
maillons faut transporter moins de
pétrole - de transport moins de
transport point de pib
parlons du pétrole dans la zone ocde
eh bien vous voyez que il est passé par
un maximum en 2006 deux ans avant lehman
brothers deux ans avant lehman brothers
le prix de l'immobilier aux états unis a
commencé à baisser à la fin de l'année
2006 c'est à dire que le déclencheur de
la crise qui fait lui-même suite le
déclencheur financier de la crise
démarrée en 2006 le déclencheur physique
de la crise démarrée en 2005 la
production mondiale de pétrole s'arrête
de croître
l'approvisionnement pétrolier des pays
de l'osce et d eux commencent à être
contraint à la baisse c'est
particulièrement sensible en europe
vous avez ici l'approvisionnement
européen en pétrole en rose ce qui vient
de la mer du nord envers ce qui est
importé et vous voyez que depuis 2006
nous avons perdu 18% du pétrole en
europe pas parce que monsieur borloo l'a
souhaité on n'a rien souhaité du tout
dans cette histoire c'est parce que
c'est contre un c'est parce que ça va
continuer ça va continuer c'est pareil
pour le gaz depuis 2005
l'approvisionnement en gaz de l'europe a
perdu 20% là dedans vous avez des
variations annuelles à cause du
chauffage mais peu importe vous voyez
que la mer du nord a entamé son déclin
en 2005 est ici vous avez pour mémoire
potentiel du ch elias tels que je
l'estiment en europe si tant est qu'on
décide d'y aller ce que pas
nécessairement une bonne idée mais de
toute façon même si on y va c'est un
game center rapide et vous avez ici
l'approvisionnement européen totale en
énergie qui est passé par un maximum en
2006 et vous voyez ce que valent les
nouvelles renouvelables dans cette
histoire en violet dans lequel on a mis
à date des centaines de milliards
d'euros bien des centaines de milliards
d'euros rien que l'allemagne en a mis
trois cent cinquante les centaines de
milliards d'euros ne change pas grand
chose
ceci alors avec solar voilà comment
évolue la production industrielle de la
france alors c'est parce que nos
politiques sont nuls donc on a viré
montebourg et ça va mieux alors voilà
comment ça se passe chez les anglais
voilà comment ça se passe chez les
danois voilà comment ça se passe chez
les suédois
voilà comment ça se passe chez les
finlandais voilà comment ça se passe
chez les allemands a également sa ses
champions du monde pourquoi parce qu ils
ont 200 milliards par an d'exportation
mais tous les pays de la terre peuvent
pas être exportateur net
donc en fait la croissance industrielle
de l'allemagne se fait juste au
détriment de la décroissance industriels
des autres pays du point quand vous avez
ici ce qui se passe pour l'espagne et
vous avez ici ce qui se passe pour
l'italie et vous avez ici ce qui se
passe pour l'union européenne j'aurais
pu vous montrer le japon c'est pareil
et même les états unis même les états
unis sont juste revenus aux niveaux de
production industrielle qu'ils avaient
en 2007
même les états unis et ceux ci allant
avec cela voilà comment a évolué le pib
dans la zone européenne
donc oui si vous avez la croissance
annuelle du pib est reporté sur les
cinquante cinq dernières années depuis
1960 et si vous faites une courbe de
tendance sur cette croissance va vous
voyez que la croissance diminue c'est
normal tout les extractions de
ressources naturelles peuvent pas
croître de plus en plus au fil des ans
et donc le pib et qui n'est que la
contrepartie monétaire de la
transformation de ces ressources ne peut
pas croître indéfiniment connaissez
cette blague sénégal bref je crois qu'il
disait si vous croisez quelqu'un qui
croit à la croissance infinie dans un
monde fini c'est un fou ou un économiste
les économistes ont la seule théorie
c'est ça le gros avantage sur les
physiciens
ils ont la seule théorie dans laquelle
n'y a pas de limite par construction
les physiciens ils n'ont pas de pot il
ya que des limites par construction dans
les théories qui manipulent n'ont quand
même pas de chance l'économie a pas de
limite par construction dans sa théorie
donc la croissance infinie est à notre
portée le seul petit bémol c'est que la
théorie est pas bonne parce que quand
vous essayer de prédire ce qui va se
passer avec la théorie ça marche pas
mais bon c'est sympa quand même
vous avez ici la même chose sur la zone
ocde et vous avez ici la même chose sur
le monde dans son ensemble donc retenu
une première chose à l'issue de cette
démonstration c'est que pour des raisons
énergétiques la croissance durable ne
reviendra pas dans la zone ocde et si
avec ça que vous allez devoir vivre
et mon sentiment c'est qu'il va y avoir
de plus en plus des marches d'escalier
dans l'autre sens et à falloir vivre
avec ça ça va faire partie du cadre dans
lequel vous allez devoir fonctionner à
l'avenir et moi au dessus du reste je
vais maintenant vous parler un tout
petit peu de climat même si valérie
masson vous en a parlé
évidemment je suis passé pas si elle
vous a présenté ce truc là qui est une
grande classique qui est évidemment là
pour rappeler que corrélation de vos pas
preuve
1 il ya aussi quelqu'un qui dans un mode
- taquin avait regardé l'évolution des
bateaux de pirates et la température
mondiale et en avait déduit que la
température mondiale augmentaient parce
que les bateaux de pirates baissait je
vais juste vous rappeler quelques petits
trucs l'effet de serre sarah deux
siècles je vous laisserai ça donc vous
le lirez attentivement et ça doit du
reste soit dit en passant aux français
quand on parle du réchauffement
climatique la variation de la
température c'est le marqueur médiatique
c'est à dire que les médias ils savent
faire que des trucs simples dont +5
degrés ça ils ont compris donc ils en
parlent mais il serait bien inspiré de
parler du reste par exemple il va y
avoir des variations fortes des
précipitations et en particulier et ça
c'est un petit lien avec le printemps
arabe
regardez ce qui se passe sur le pourtour
du bassin méditerranéen de moins en
moins de précipitation donc une
production agricole qui va de plus en
plus souffrir une production agricole
qui souffre de plus en plus avec une
population de plus en plus nombreuse
avait plein d'exemples historiques de ce
que ça donne ça s'appelle des
révolutions ça marche très bien
ça marche très bien
vous avez d'autres choses donc les
rendements agricoles vont souffrir les
écosystèmes risque de souffrir la
biodiversité des maladies pourrait
augmenter
vous allez avoir une augmentation de
l'intensité à minima des phénomènes
extrêmes l'océan se dilatant falot ce
qui l'attend dans l'océan on va monter
l'océan va ça s'est dit fier avec des
effets tout à fait inconnu sur les
écosystèmes marins
vous allez avoir une modification de la
circulation à grande échelle dans
l'océan il ya une déstabilisation déjà
en cours du groenland et potentiel de
l'antarctique de l'ouest
ça j'en ai déjà parlé vous avez des
phénomènes d'amplification dans le
système qui pourrait larguer des
réservoirs de carbone qui sont immobiles
depuis des millions d'années
le point important ces derniers quand
vous faites une expérience pour la
première fois ça n'a strictement aucun
sens de demander à quelqu'un de vous
décrire par le menu tout ce qui peut se
passer pendant l'expérience aux
questions alors je vais prendre une
expérience que les hommes ont fait trois
milliards de fois que s'appelle se
marier mais peut-être quelques personnes
dans la salle qui sont concernés un mari
l'a fait ça 3 milliards 4 milliard de
fois non track-record bien fait un
certain nombre de voix on peut faire des
nuages de points des régressions des
machins trucs débiles va pour autant
prenez un couple qui se marie
aujourd'hui vous êtes un foutu de dire
ce que sera ce couple dans 30 ans alors
que pourtant on a fait l'expérience
trois milliards de fois maintenant vous
prenez une expérience que vous faites
pour la première fois grandeur nature
qui s'appelle réchauffer un climat de 5
degrés en un siècle ou en deux siècles
ça n'a pas le moindre sens de demander à
la communauté scientifique de vous faire
l'inventaire précis de tous les
emmerdements qu'on peut avoir dans ce
cadre là ça n'a pas de sens pas de sens
j'insiste pas de sens
par contre ce qui a du sens c'est de
rapprocher sa du passé pour comprendre
qu'on est en train de secouer le système
dans des proportions telles que la
probabilité pour qu'on n'est pas dans
mes romans majeurs et rigoureusement nul
ça ça a du sens et c'est ça que je vais
vous dire tout de suite vous avez ici je
sais pas si valérie vous avez vous la
montrer cette carte ou pas non
les écosystèmes qui sont installés en
europe si on leur fout la paix
aujourd'hui
alors si on leur fout la paix ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on coupe pas
les forêts pour faire des champions par
les forêts pour faire des routes des
aéroports et des écoles des ponts bref
on laisse les écosystèmes vivre leur vie
et on regarde ce qu'on a et bien si on
fait ça voilà les écosystèmes qui sont
aujourd'hui installés en europe vous
avez essentiellement de la forêt ce qui
veut dire que les conditions climatiques
sont sympa puisque la forêt est en
général l'écosystème le plus riche en
biodiversité que vous puissiez avoir
quelque part si les conditions s'y
prêtent donc vous avez essentiellement
de la forêt boréale méditerranéenne tout
au nord il fait trop froid donc trop sec
pour que vous ayez de la forêt tout à
l'est il fait trop sec pour que vous
ayez de la forêt mais partout ailleurs
c'est plutôt de la forêt que vous avez
voici l'europe des vingt mille ans
or l'europe dix à vingt mille ans ne
ressemble pas vraiment à l'europe
d'aujourd'hui
comme vous pouvez le constater la
première chose qui se passe c'est je
sais pas si l'école des ponts accueille
aujourd'hui des élèves suédois danois au
finlandais mais je peux vous dire que il
ya vingt mille ans c'était pas possible
parce qu'ils étaient sur la glace il y
avait une calotte de trois kilomètres
d'épaisseur qui était posé sur la
scandinavie et soit dit en passant il y
en avait également une autre qui était
posée sur le nord de l'ecosse donc les
écossais étaient pas là pour nous
emmerder au rugby ça c'est quand même
une bonne nouvelle
vous voyez que le trait de côte
passe à l'extérieur de la grande
bretagne actuelle alors pour ceux
d'entre vous qui font de la voile pas
trop vous êtes quand même là pour
étudier
vous savez probablement que le point bas
de la manche aujourd'hui ses 110 m 114
très exactement si j'ai bien regardé mon
sauveur
donc c'est une mère qui n'existaient pas
la manche
il y a vingt mille ans puisque l'océan
avait baissé de 120 mètres où étaient
passés l'eau qui n'est plus dans l'océan
dans les énormes calotte qui était sur
la scandinavie l'antarctique avaient
grossi le groenland avait grossi et il y
avait une énorme calotte également posé
sur le canada la calotte de laurentides
vous voyez qu'il n'y a pas vraiment de
forêts en europe à cette époque là la
totalité de l'écosystème européen
ressemble plus ou moins à ce qu'on
trouve aujourd'hui dans le nord de la
sibérie
vous avez un peu partout de la step etc
et du coup la capacité à nourrir des
bons hommes du système france du système
agricole france à l'époque
c'est à peu près la population de
boulogne billancourt
pour donc un peu moins puisque ces cent
cinquante mille personnes boulogne
billancourt donc l'écosystème france le
système agricole france à cette époque
là au grand dam de la fnsea ne se
nourrir que cent mille personnes qui
vivent de chasse et de cueillette à
gauche il ya vingt mille ans à droite
aujourd'hui quelle est la différence
entre ces deux états de l'europe est
bien la différence entre ces deux états
de l'europe c'est 5 degrés sur la
moyenne planétaire
il ya vingt mille ans la terre était en
aire glaciaire en aire glaciaire
la température moyenne de la planète est
inférieur de 5 degrés à ce qu'elle est
alors j'allais dire aujourd'hui à
l'époque préindustrielle plus exactement
5 degrés 5° en 5000 en fait la
transformation que vous avez soulevé en
faire une règle de trois 5° en 5000 ans
ça fait 1 degré en bilan ça fait 0 1
degré par siècle 0,1 degré par siècle
soutenue sur quelques dizaines de
siècles
ça vous fait ça alors je vous pose la
question est-ce que vous pensez que
quelques degrés en un siècle ça va être
une promenade de santé
non pas du tout ça va pas du tout est un
peu prendre de santé ça va pas du tout
est un problème de maillots de bain en
plus ou en moins
à cette époque là quand les gens
devaient déménager ils étaient quelques
millions sur terre en la population
mondiale était de 5 millions sur le
paysage de gauche
et puis le choix démocratique était pas
vraiment le sujet donc quand vous devez
déménager monsieur chefs de tribus
prendraient une grosse massue de taper
sur la tête de madame chefs de tribus et
des enfants chef de tribu tirait tout le
monde par les cheveux on prenait trois
crayons pour barbouillé la grotte
d'après deux paniers un harpon et claque
c'était terminé
aujourd'hui vous avez 7 milliards de
bronze abcès dentaire sur terre et vous
n'allez pas déménager avec sur votre dos
l'école des ponts notre dame les
raffineries les centrales électriques
les routes les usines les ports etc
ça n'existe pas ça et puis si vous allez
vous mettre dans un endroit qui est
sympa avec 7 milliards de grosses sommes
sur terre il ya une forte probabilité
pour qu'il ait déjà des gens ils sont
pas d'accord pour voir arriver donc ce
que signifie 5 degrés en un siècle ou
quatre ou trois c'est essentiellement un
monde qui va devenir chaotique et
guerrier c'est ça que ça signifie je
suis pas en train de vous parler d'un
maillot d'un on s'en fou d'un maillot de
bain je suis en train de vous parler de
la stabilité politique
social de l'espérance de vie est de la
taille de la population
c'est de ça dont on est en train de
parler voilà je finis avec j'ai été un
tout petit peu long non le reste je vais
garder pour les questions j'avais dit
que j'aurai une règle de trois mais
c'est pas grave je vais je vais finir
avec ça rentre voilà ça aurait pu durer
cinq secondes
c'est ça mon résumé que nous le voulions
ou pas que nous le voulions ou pas
l'énergie a tout fait dans le monde qui
nous entoure à 7 millions bon homme sur
terre
il n'ya plus assez d'énergie pour qu'on
en ait de plus en plus partout et tout
le temps et il ya trop d'énergie fossile
pour qu'on ait un climat qui reste
stable donc qu'on le veuille ou qu'on ne
le veulent pas de toute façon l'énergie
sera le grand défi de ce siècle
merci
merci beaucoup jean marc jancovici pour
ça provoquant alarmant presque déprimant
vous avez je pense car effectivement
beaucoup de questions sur le constat
mais peut-être aussi sur les pistes pour
les solutions face à cette grande ce
grand problème donc voilà sans plus
tarder voilà une première question
rapidement si vous avez des pistes de
solution alors je vais vous retourner la
question qu'est ce que vous appelez une
solution une solution c'est quelque
chose qui permet d'obtenir quoi qui
permettrait par exemple de voir enfin je
pense là une cohésion au niveau
international pour niveau des décisions
alors une cohésion international fait
partie des derniers trucs qu'on aura
parce que les les comment dire la
distance au problème est extrêmement
variable en fonction des pays que vous
regardez et les envies sont extrêmement
variables les cultures sont extrêmement
variables selon par exemple que la vie
est la première valeur ou pas dans votre
culture vous n'avez pas du tout le même
genre de réponse face à ce problème
donc la cohésion international
n'existera jamais ce qui peut exister
c'est des accords internationaux sur des
points à peu près 6 hélas si vous pensez
par exemple à ce qu'il va se passer à
paris dans quelques mois ce qui va se
passer à paris dans quelques mois ne
changera pas fondamentalement la manière
dont les pays s'organisent face à ce
problème ça le changera un peu mais ça
ne changera pas fondamentalement pour
une raison très simple c'est que les
nations unies n'ont pas le pouvoir
d'envoyer les chars chez les gens qui se
comportent d'une manière qui est
considéré comme déviantes par les
nations unies on leur a sauf dans un cas
très particulier qui est les décisions
du conseil de sécurité mais pour le
moment le climat ne relève pas
donc le ce qui va se passer les nations
unies c'est un système
mon temps dans lequel chaque pays
dispose d'une voix donc les états unis
et les îles tuvalu ont le même pouvoir
aux nations-unies et les décisions
doivent être obtenus par consensus
tout le monde doit être d'accord sur ce
qu'on fait alors je sais pas si vous
avez déjà été dans une assemblée de
copropriétaires déjà été dans une
assemblée de copropriétaires
non ban qui a déjà été dans une
assemblée de copropriétaires ici vous
connaissez un peu le alors imaginez 198
copropriétaires 198 qu'ils voteraient à
une assemblée de copropriétaires
indépendamment de la surface de leur
appartement donc celui qui a un placard
à balais à une voix comme celui qui a le
triplex au sommet de l'immeuble qui
doivent décider d'une augmentation des
charges qui n'ont pas a priori la clé de
répartition et qui ne savent pas qui est
le bénéficiaire de l'augmentation des
charges qui vont voter et ces gens là
doivent se mettre d'accord de manière
totalement unanime
quelle est la probabilité qu'on y arrive
donc c'est exactement ce qui se passe
aux négociations climat la probabilité
qu'on y arriver nulle part ailleurs vous
avez bien compris que diminuer les
émissions de co2 c'est diminuer la
consommation d'énergies fossiles
diminuer la consommation d'énergies
fossiles c'est diminuer la consommation
d'énergie tout court diminuer l'énergie
disponible ci diminue le pib donc les
négociations climat ne sont pas très
loin de ressembler à une discussion sur
la meilleure manière d'organiser la
décroissance
physiquement c'est sans question quelle
est la probabilité qu'on y arrive donc
le l'accord international dans cette
affaire c'est la dernière chose qu'on
aura le jour où un certain nombre de
pays en quantité croissante il faut le
souhaiter
et pour des raisons strictement égoïste
donc intérieur décideront de s'exciter
face à ce problème parce qu'ils
comprendront que toutes choses égales
par ailleurs c'est leur meilleure option
alors dans cette catégorie là j'en vois
déjà deux très significatif 1 c'est
l'europe
mais il faut que l'europe comprenne
qu'elle est déjà sous stress
d'approvisionnement en combustibles
fossiles et que ça va s'accélérer
donc de toutes façons décarbonés
l'économie c'est sa meilleure option
mais on a vachement de mal à faire
accepter cette idée
mais là je vais faire une petite
digression sur les médias parce que le
problème le plus mise en avant dans les
médias et le problème climatique est pas
le problème de stress
d'approvisionnement et la raison liée à
ça c'est que le problème climatique
procède d'un mouvement militant et d'une
science disponibles qui sont là donc il
ya un mouvement militant et une séance
disponible en ce qui concerne la décrue
énergétique il ya ni l'un ni l'autre
il n'y a pas le mouvement militant et
l'information n'est pas disponible parce
que pour avoir une vue qui commence à
être à peu près complète de ce qu'est
vraiment l'approvisionnement en
combustibles fossiles quelque part il
faut avoir passé cinq ans de déjeuner un
peu alcoolisé avec des gens qui
acceptent de se lâcher pour qu'ils vous
donnent des informations qui sont pas
dans le domaine public parce que les
informations sur la réalité des
productions et des réserves sont des
informations détenues par des opérateurs
commerciaux et elles sont pas dans le
domaine public donc il faut y aller à la
mado c'est un travail de fourmi
changement climatique c'est que de la
recherche publiée donc pour peu que vous
en donniez la peine tout est disponible
donc le l'europe il y aurait intérêt est
le deuxième pays qui a intéressé la
chine parce que la chine est comme
l'europe un peuple à la traduction à la
pardon à l'existence multimillénaire
c'est des gens qui savent réfléchir
c'est des gens qui ont bien compris que
1 milliards et quelques dans la taille
du pays ça allait poser des problèmes
c'est des gens qui sont capables de voir
à 30 ou 40 ans encore et c'est des gens
ou les élites urbaines
c'est peut-être plus important et
j'aurais peut-être dû commencer par ça
donc les élites au pouvoir commence à
trouver intolérable de la pollution des
centrales à charbon
peut-être dû commencer par ça donc il ya
deux blocs à mon avis qui sont
intéressants à regarder c'est la chine
et l'europe
il se trouve que conjoncturellement les
etats-unis sont aussi sur la bonne pente
parce que remplaçant du charbon par du
gaz même de schiste ils font baisser
leurs émissions mais à mon avis c'est
plus conjoncturels que structurels parce
que vous savez quand même que le slogan
des états unis ces deux limites
donc nos limites pour se confronter à un
problème qui n'est qu'un problème de
limites c'est quand même un peu
compliqué mais voila voila en gros mais
la communauté internationale ne donnera
pas la solution ce qui va donner la
solution c'est un empilement d'actions
nationales ou régionales
c'est à ce niveau là c'est à cette
échelle là qu'il faut aller chercher le
début de l'initiative
il ya un autre endroit aussi qui peut
être intéressant à regarder ses débuts
petit national des médias giral c'est
celles capitalistes etc
oui sauf que là dedans il y en a qui ont
un intérêt direct à l'action et que les
multinationales sont les seules
institutions transnationales capable
d'imposer une discipline interne il n'y
a pas d'autres face il ya la
construction européenne et à part la
construction européenne multinationales
c'est donc chez elle il ya évidemment à
boire et à manger
mais c'est aussi le monde économique est
enfin de ce cliver sur ce sujet il ya
dix ans ils étaient unanimes à dire vous
nous emmerdez avec les contraintes sur
les émissions aujourd'hui c'est plus du
tout le sait plus du tout le discours
est pour vous donner un exemple assez
rigolo est très récent le patron de
total aujourd'hui milite pour une
augmentation du prix du co2 en europe
il est fou il est pas du tout fou c'est
la condition à laquelle le gaz peut
déplacer le charbon aujourd'hui ce qui
est en train de se passer c'est que la
production électrique au gaz est en
train de se casser la gueule et la
production électrique au charbon en
train de très bien se porter et le
patron de total dix ce serait quand même
mieux si c'est l inverse du point de vue
du co2 y a pas tort et la seule
condition pour y arriver c'est que le
co2 veille quelque chose et tu y vas y
suffisamment cher pour que les centrales
à charbon soient défavorisées
économiquement par rapport aux centrales
au gaz
donc ce brave homme est en train
d'entraîner tout a pas de pétroliers
européens appui mondiaux dans l'idée
qu'il faut monter le prix du co2 et il
le fait pas du tout par raisons
altruistes encore que j'ai vu sa fille
comme elle a via deux ans maintenant
parlons donc mais il le fait avant tout
parce que c'est parfaitement cohérent
avec le mandat qui est le sien de
diriger cette boutique qui est
parfaitement cohérent donc c'est ça que
je voulais dire quand je dis le monde
est en train de se clive et
économiquement là-dessus et il faut
aller chercher les gagnants de la faire
en gros il faut faire le lobby
économique des gagnants potentiels de la
sphère qui sont très loin d'être juste
les opérateurs et les fabricants de
panneaux photovoltaïques et d'éoliennes
très loin si je peux préciser un petit
peu du couvain approfondie un peu la
question en termes de solutions est-ce
que vous avez des idées de solutions
techniques plus que deux solutions
politiques pour
ils ont arrivés une transition plus
douce alors là c'est toujours pareil ça
dépend ce que vous mettez derrière le
mot solution si vous mettez choses à
faire qu'il faut faire de toute façon
parce que si on les fait on se portera
mieux que si on les fait pas alors là
j'en ai toute une liste que je peux vous
énoncez rapidement de la première des
choses à faire
ça va être un peu inventaire à la
prévert il ya une action à avoir dans le
domaine des transports et dans le
domaine des transports les deux grandes
marges d'action s'appelle réglementer la
consommation des voitures neuves
taxer les véhicules à la détention au
prorata de leur consommation
taxer de manière croissante les
carburants augmenter l'offre de bus
parce que le train est beaucoup trop
capitalistique en termes
d'infrastructures pour permettre de
déplacer rapidement de la voiture c'est
le bus qui peut s'en charger promouvoir
le vélo et le covoiturage et à long
terme dégonfler les villes les villes de
10 millions d'habitants sont pas viables
dans un monde à l'énergie contraintes et
faire des doigts you urbain dense bien
réparties sur le territoire avec un
hinterland qui permettent
l'approvisionnement en donner et sans
enfant dans résidentiel pardon sans
avoir besoin de faire dix mille
kilomètres à chaque fois vous avez un
deuxième sujet sur le bâti qui est
d'essayer de faire en sorte que les gens
divorcent moins parce que plus vie
divorce et plus vous avez besoin de
surfaces construites à population
identique c'est pas du tout une blague
vous avez un la consommation d'énergie
des gens quand ils divorcent augmente de
60 % instantanément donc j'ai une bonne
ou une mauvaise nouvelle à vous donner
ça sera plus compliqué pour votre
génération de divorce et que ça ne l'a
été pour la mienne donc choisissez mieux
vous avez donc un vous avez donc un un
sujet sur le bâti donc non ce n'est pas
le cas ce jeudi ainsi il ya une
inflation perpétuelle de la demande en
mètres carrés par personne
vous pouvez faire tout ce que vous
voulez sur le plan technique vous y
arrivez pas à quoi donc le vous avez un
et en termes purement technique vous
avez la performance de leurs enveloppes
et les appareils de chauffage et pour
être un peu pragmatique il faut isoler
mais sans excès et tout passer à la
pompe à chaleur et construire quelques
réacteurs nucléaires pour pour alimenter
tout ça sur le plan de l'électricité il
faut tuer le charbon est remplacé sa
part du nucléaire on sera pas dans les
temps jamais si on essaye avec du
photovoltaïque et de l'éolien donc
aujourd'hui les gens à l'enfer est pavé
de bonnes intentions comme vous le savez
aujourd'hui les gens qui disent on va
remplacer les fossiles par du
photovoltaïque et de l'éolien
malheureusement pour eux ne font que le
vrai pour que le changement climatique
soit plus important c'est ça qui font en
pratique évidemment si vous leur dit
qu'ils vont dire que je suis fou mais en
pratique c'est ça qu'ils font c'est un
peu comme si vous dites à renault dont
les ventes de voiture diminue vend donc
des trombones et tu vas garder le même
nombre d'emplois
donc il faut donc il faut tuer le
charbon dans la production électrique
mondiale
en france on en a pas énormément donc là
ce que je suis en train de vous dire
concerne part à la france directement
pour ses installations par contre ça
concerne directement la france pour son
industrie
on peut quand même en exporter trois et
demi si on rentre dans ce genre de chez
vous vous avez en ce qui concerne
l'industrie il va falloir se faire à
l'idée que les objets vont redevenir
plus durable plus cher plus réparable et
moins accessible plus cher insiste donc
le fait que la production industrielle
diminue c'est le sens de l'histoire
par contre il faut que l'on n'ait pas
besoin de changer le frigo tous les
trois ans
l'ordinateur tous les trois ans et c'est
donc et tout ça va de pair avec un
système économique dans lequel ça coûte
plus cher on en prend plus soin les
performances changement est souvent et
c'est ça va également de pair avec un
truc que je auxquelles je crois beaucoup
il ya un
un ingénieur qui s'appelle philippe
bihouix % d'entre vous le connaissent et
qui a écrit en qu'un qui s'appelle l'âge
des low tech que je vous recommande et
dans lequel il fait cette réflexion qui
est honteux de ne l'avoir eue quand le
disant parce que c'est tellement évident
si vous voulez recycler de manière
significative
vous ne pouvez pas faire du high tech
parce que le high tech consiste à
mélanger les deux tiers du tableau de
mendeleïev dans n'importe quel objet que
vous faites et ensuite vous n'arrivez
pas à aller récupérer les éléments
unitairement les uns derrière les autres
donc si vous voulez récupérer facilement
l'acier vous pouvez pas faire des tas
d'alliages spéciaux pour des tas
d'usagés spéciaux sinon vous y arrivez
pas et c'est donc ce que dit bihouix qui
est frappé au coin du bon sens si on
veut beaucoup recyclé faut faire du low
tech et pas du high tech c'est très
perturbant pour les ingénieurs que nous
sommes mais il ya quelque chose de
fondamentalement vrai dans ses remarques
donc il faut faire simple modulaire des
constructibles et c'est en ce qui
concerne le
l'agriculture pour finir il faut
remettre quelques millions de personnes
dans l'activité agroalimentaire au sens
large mais pas au sens de l'industrie
qui concentre tout transforme tout il
redistribue tout mais au sens des gens
qui vont s'occuper plus près du sol donc
plus localement
d'abord de remettre un peu le sol en
état mais ça ça concerne plus les agro
goût et ensuite d'avoir des cirques il
n'y a aucune raison qu'on fasse tous les
poulets de france en bretagne je veux
dire je pense pas que les poulets soit
plus malheureux quand ils sont en trois
ans sous 1 strasbourg enfin en tout cas
si on leur demandait leur avis je pense
que c'est ce qui irait donc et il y
avait un truc qui était très simple au
début pour pas avoir les emmerdements au
sens propre du cochon en bretagne et les
engrais de synthèse dans la cause qui
était de faire chier les cochons dans la
brousse marché très bien donc on a un
vrai problème qui est de revenir à une
forme de polyculture élevage ou un peu
plus à une forme de polyculture élevage
c'est clair que l'on va pas mettre des
palmiers dans la beauce mais enfin on
peut quand même un peu plus diversifier
les cultures
histoire d'être moins dépendant aux
transports aval il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui un tiers des camions qui
circulent en france transportent un truc
qui se mange donc la vraie dépendance au
pétrole du système agroalimentaire et
pas dans les champs elle est à laval
elle est dans le système aval jeu
spécialise je concentre je transforme je
distribue tout ça ça tient pas avec une
énergie en contraction
donc il faut remettre des gens dans
l'activité agricole pour mieux exploiter
les mètres carrés de sol avec moins
d'intrants et plus transformé donc plus
maître de valeur ajoutée près de la
production est moins dans des endroits
qui sont éloignés de centaines de
milliers ou des dizaines de milliers de
kilomètres donc tout ça il faut aussi
dégonfler les unités productives la
mondialisation ça marche pas avec peu de
pétrole
donc vous avez tout ce travail qui va
être à faire rien de tout ça ne fera
revenir la croissance économique si
c'est ça la question
par contre tout ça donne des tapes
projets qui peuvent avoir un sens et à
titre personnel si on s'y prend bien si
on est dans un système dans lequel
chaque année au gagnant 1 % de moins que
ce qu'on gagne la des précédents je
pense que c'est pas un drame
c'est à dire que si vous et moi on gagne
1% l'année prochaine en moins de ce
qu'on gagne cette année où s'organisent
le drame c'est qu'aujourd'hui comme
chacun s'accroche à ses avantages le 1 %
en moins et concentrées sur un pour cent
de la population qui passe de
ou à rien à eux ça leur fait tout drôle
donc on va avoir aussi besoin de
réinventer le dialogue social
ça va aussi vous concerné parce que pour
ceux d'entre vous qui ont des postes à
responsabilités plus tard je peux vous
assurer que ça va vous concerne et moi
j'ai des négociations salariales dans
mon entreprise
pourtant avec des gens éduqués puisqu'il
ya que des cadres supérieurs c'est une
boîte de consultants et ben rien qu'à
eux leur faire comprendre que quand
l'inflation est nulle n'y a pas de
raison d'accorder des augmentations
générales ben oui allez donc vous il va
y avoir besoin de réinventer le et ils
sont tous par ailleurs pour le partage
le machin la générosité votre problème
donc on va avoir besoin de réinventer le
dialogue social donc tout est à
réinventer dans cette affaire puisque
comme vous l'avez compris l'énergie nous
a permis de vivre sur une grosse bulle
de chewing gum qui arrêtait pas de se
dilater et il va falloir inventer tout a
pas de mécanisme qui sont pas
compatibles avec cette dilatation
perpétuelle donc en termes de créativité
ça peut ça pourrait être une époque
absolument formidable et enfin le
dernier point c'est qu'il va falloir
faire tout un tas de trucs pour le
changement climatique déjà embarqués
parce que à cause ça c'est un truc que
valeria de vous expliquer à cause de
l'inertie de l'océan en particulier si
on s'arrête des maîtres demain matin de
toute façon il ya encore un certain
nombre de compartiments du système
climatique qui vont continuer à dériver
pendant des milliers d'années
de toute façon donc le lot il va aussi
falloir s'occuper de ça vous avez
beaucoup parlé du premier principe de la
thermodynamique mais nous en cours nous
en a appris d'eux est ce que le deuxième
est une importance oui le deuxième il
était implicite dans ce que je vous ai
dit sur le rayonnement à 3 degrés kelvin
de l'univers voilà typiquement une
quantité d'énergie qui au regard du
premier principe est énorme
par contre on regarde le deuxième
principe vous en ferai jamais rien n'est
rhji éolienne ou hydroliennes sont des
énergies qui sont plus intéressantes
oui mais elles sont très diffuses elles
sont extrêmement diffuse donc il vaut
mieux avoir un rendement dégueulasse sur
une énergie très concentré qu'un
rendement excellent sur une énergie très
diffuse à l'arrivée vous y retrouver
quand même avec l'énergie très concentré
il ya un autre truc que vous savez
probablement c'est que l'électricité en
tant que tel ne se stocke pas parce que
l'électricité se définit par des
électrons en mouvement il ya que dans
des supraconducteurs que vous savez
stocker des électrons en mouvement sinon
vous devez transformer l'électricité en
une autre forme d'énergie pour la
stocker et il se trouve que toutes les
formes de stockage de l'électricité que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui suppose la
mise en jeu de masse qui sont
extrêmement significative et c'est ça
qui pénalise l'électricité dans l' usage
transport
là où le pétrole est roi parce que dans
un réservoir de pétrole
vous avez dit kilowattheures par litre
alors que dans 1 kg de batteries plomb
acide vous avez 35 watts heure et même
les batteries pouet pouet moderne la
lithium-ion etc
vous avez des densité énergétique qui
restent de l'ordre de 150 200 watts
heure par kilo donc vous voyez vous êtes
un facteur 10 plus quelque chose plutôt
50 en dessous de la densité énergétique
du pétrole donc l'électricité quand vous
l'obtenez effectivement vous l'obtenez
avec un bon rendement quand vous devez
la stocker là le rendement se dégradent
extrêmement fortement
bonjour vous semble être assez
pessimiste quant aux aux aboutissement
de la cap 21 et vont les effets un
scénario assez acquis peuple elliptique
soit 5 degrés mais ce cas votre avis de
degré c'est possible ou bien
physiquement oui est-ce qu'on va y
arriver je suis pas madame soleil est ce
que c'est une élévation de température
sans emmerdements non est ce que c'est
une élévation de température avec
emmerdements qui sont susceptibles de
diviser la taille de la population
humaine par deux je n'en sais rien parce
qu'en plus ça sera pas le seul facteur
de pression sur la taille de la
population humaine y aura aussi des
stocks d'énergie et comme on va écrire
l'histoire qu'une seule fois
l'attribution des causes sera pas simple
là où certains d'entre vous connaissent
peut-être s'appelle brice lalonde
non c'est un arbre remarquable brice
lalonde a été le directeur de campagne
du premier candidat aux élections
présidentielles il était un écolo en 74
rené dumont c'est un franco-américain
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'il est
il est big horn et comme il l'est il a
été de tous les coups de l'environnement
depuis très longtemps 74
ça commence à faire un peu et en
particulier il était ministre de
l'environnement mitterrand au moment du
sommet de la terre en 92 à rio qui est
le sommet où a été signée la convention
climat il a fait toutes les réunions
internationales sur le climat depuis
lors tout est bien il a une petite
blague qui est si on en est à la coop
21/21 c'est parce que ça fait 20 ans
qu'on n'y arrive pas et sa petite blague
elle est parfaitement fondé le système
même des nations unies fait que on
n'arrivera pas à faire des choses
discriminante dans cette enceinte
il est rare fois on y arrive je vais
vous parler de copenhague puisque j
étais la presse emmenés par des gens
bien pensants pour prendre un terme
approprié dit ah c'est pas bien que ça
se passe comme ça alors ce qui s'est
passé à copenhague ce que j étais ça a
été un hold up du g20 sur les nations
unies tiers qu'à un moment les puissants
ont dit vous les mioches la vo gueule ça
va être comme ça il y a que comme ça que
ça peut marcher
y a que comme ça que ça peut marcher si
vous décidez du programme d'enseignement
de la première année en dix ans chaque
personne on part d'une feuille blanche
et chaque personne dans cette enceinte à
une voie et on doit y arriver de manière
unanime penser que ça va marcher
bon si le directeur des études dit c'est
comme ça et pas autrement je pense que
ça marche un peu lieu donc enfin en tout
cas vous avez un résultat donc c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé à
copenhague à copenhague ce qui s'est
passé est là le jeu tient l'information
de source sûre donc c'est vraiment un
truc qu'on peut mettre à son crédit
c'est dans la deuxième semaine des
négociations dans la nuit du jeudi au
vendredi sarkozy qui a dit on peut pas
repartir tous chez nous comme ça avec
rien donc merkel vient ici cameron viens
ici obama vient ici etc
on va faire une réunion entre nous et on
va dire ce qu'on a envie de faire donc
ils sont mis dans une pièce noire
enfin non éclairée en fait
ils ont commencé à discuter entre eux
ils ont fait ce que font des présidents
dans une enceinte pareil c'est à dire
qu'ils l'ont drafté deux pages 12 items
en disant ah ben voilà on se met
d'accord là dessus ça s'appelle le début
d'un agenda politique qui n'existait pas
jusqu'à maintenant faire que jusqu'à
maintenant les gens se réunissaient mais
il savait pas si l'objectif c'était deux
trois quatre cinq six ou sept degrés non
on est sortis de cette pièce c'était 2
degrés c'était 100 milliards pour le
fonds s'est c'est donc avec le début
d'un agenda politique
c'est un succès c'est un succès la
presse a qualifié cet échec est pourquoi
la presse a qualifié cet échec parce que
les ong étaient pas voix au chapitre et
que c'est elle qui sont les premières à
se précipiter devant les micros
donc comme elle en était pas l on dit
c'est un échec et le bruit est parti
donc non seulement les négociations
internationales sont pas nécessairement
fait pour ce que vous croyez qu'elles
font et en plus quand il ya des avancées
il arrive que la presse unanime dix
c'était parce qu'il fallait faire donc
je suis pas pessimiste je suis juste un
peu taquin en dix ans mais je jeu ce qui
est important avec ces négociations
c'est pas qu'on négocie c'est qu'on en
parle dit autrement le principal
avantage de ces réunions c'est que ça
fait monter le sujet sur l'agenda
médiatique au moins une fois par an de
manière significative et que ça du coup
ça fait monter le sujet sur l'agenda
politique parce que si c'est dans les
médias c'est sur l'agenda politique et
réciproquement
donc ça a quand même un avantage de ce
point de vue par contre les décisions
techniques importantes elles ne sont pas
prises dans ce genre d'enceinte
sauf en cas de hold up donc ce qu'il
faudrait c'est que parallèlement le
climat devienne un sujet de conférences
présidentiel annuel
typiquement dans l'enceinte du g20 et la
sarre accélérait encore le
le processus sinon pour le reste je suis
pas plus pessimiste quand je vous dis à
mon âge je cours de moins en moins vite
tous les ans c'est la vie on fait avec
après la question c'est est-ce que ça
m'empêche fondamentalement d'être
heureux ou pas et si la réponse est non
parce que j'ai d'autres raisons
d'occuper mon esprit mon temps mon etc
et ça me va bien
fabien quoi donc cela ce que je vous ai
dit c'est à partir de maintenant la
croissance économique c'est du passé
enfin sauf sursaut temporaire
bon ben c'est la vie c'est pas très
grave ce qui est grave c'est que ça
privent de la capacité à faire tout
projet qui soit compatible avec ce cadre
ça c'est emmerdant bon mais ce n'est pas
le cas bonjour encore une ou deux
questions
bonjour vous avez produit entre le
changement climatique et le printemps
arabe ce que pouvaient le détail un tout
petit peu plus j'ai besoin de cinq
minutes je les ai alors le printemps
arabe
il démarre avec deux éléments qui sont
le plafonnement de la production
pétrolière mondiale en 2005 et qui est
très cohérent avec le problème
énergétique et la canicule historique
qui a eu en russie en 2010 ce qui est
très cohérente avec le changement
climatique
le plafonnement de la production
mondiale de pétrole en 2005
comme je lé rapidement dit tout à
l'heure mais je vais y revenir a eu pour
effet de casser la croissance économique
à partir de 2006 2007 dans un nombre
croissant de pays et ce tassement de la
croissance est venue percuter de plein
fouet
l'accumulation de dettes qui avait
commencé à se développer en réponse au
premier choc pétrolier ou
en fait c'est une amplification de ce
qui s'est passé au moment du premier
choc pétrolier moins de pétrole par an
et du coup on essaye de relancer
l'économie
avec des investissements en faisant
crédit à tout le monde et comme
l'économie ne se relance pas parce que
l'énergie est pas là à la niveau qu'il
faudrait pour que l'économie reparte
comme avant
eh bien on se retrouve avec les
investissements donc les emprunts et pas
les revenus en face qui permettent de
les rembourser et donc un stock de
dettes qui s'accroît et depuis les chocs
pétroliers on a inventé la dette
perpétuelle c'est une pyramide de ponzi
un endettement qu'on a depuis les chocs
pétroliers c'est à dire chaque année
j'emprunte plus pour rembourser ce que
j'ai emprunté l'année de l'année
précédente
très exactement ce qu'a fait madoff
exactement la même chose sauf que pour
le moment moody's dit ça vaut doubleurs
donc le en 2005 le phénomène s'accélère
encore sauf que cette fois ci ça craque
vous avez un défaut une crise financière
le crise financière provoque un
rattrapage de l'économie dans l'autre
sens et en 2009 -3% de pib à ce moment
quelles sont les dépenses dans lesquels
les consommateurs occidentaux vont
tailler en premier vous avez notamment
les dépenses de voyages et donc les
touristes qui se rendaient en tunisie et
en egypte un peu moins en algérie et au
maroc décide de s'y rendre un peu moins
baisse des recettes à l'exportation pour
ces pays-là 2010 canicule historique en
russie la russie produit annuellement à
peu près 100 millions de tonnes de
céréales dont la moitié par en
exportations sur le marché mondial
il faut savoir que le marché mondial des
céréales est un marché très étroit parce
que seulement 10% de la production
mondiale de céréales passe une frontière
c'est un petit marché ont produit chaque
année 2 milliards de tonnes de céréales
200 millions passent les frontières en
ordre de grandeur est là dedans quelques
dizaines de millions de tonnes sont le
fait de la russie ces dizaines de
millions de tonnes over night la russie
dit c'est à dessein 0 soir de juillet 20
jours de juillet la russie 17 années
jeunes exporterait pas le lendemain le
cours des céréales à chicago pour les 30
% 30 %
et si vous regardez comment a évolué le
cours des céréales sur l'année 2010 il a
doublé dans l'année
j'en reviens à l'egypte et à la tunisie
l'égypte est le plus gros importateur de
blé au monde population en croissance 4
un million bonshommes production
alimentaire insuffisante j'ai oublié un
autre truc avec le changement climatique
que je vous ai montré tout à l'heure
l'assèchement du pourtour du bassin
méditerranéen qui directement contraint
à la baisse la production agricole de
ces pays donc production agricole qui
arrive pas à croître importateurs lourds
défauts de devises qu'est ce qui se
passe en 2010 et début 2011 le prix de
l'alimentation explose puisque les
céréales voient leur cours doublé et à
la suite tous ceux qui se bouffent voit
son cours doubler parce que toutes les
commodités sont asservis donc la viande
double led double lui il double le sucre
double double l'égyptien standard et on
va dire les 50% qui gagnent le moins il
a un dollar par jour de revenu net
disponible c'est-à-dire que si vous
regardez ce qu'ils gagnent moins les
impôts etc
un dollar par jour la tonne de céréales
coûte 200 dollars si vous regardez ce
que représente le doublement de la tonne
de céréales pour une personne qui mange
un kilo de pain par jour
faites le calcul c'est une simple règle
de trois eh bien vous arrivé à la
conclusion que le budget alimentaire de
cette personne double alors qu'elle
occupait déjà à peu près la moitié de ce
qu'il gagne sinon plus 1789
les gens sont descendus dans la rue
parce qu'ils n'avaient plus à bouffer et
parce que le gouvernement privé devise
était incapable de subventionner les
importations prenaient l'algérie qui a
du gaz et du pétrole
pas des votes prenez le maroc qui a un
pouvoir à une alimentation à peu près
autosuffisante pas des bottes prenez la
syrie mal connecté au marché mondial à
cause de son régime politique qui
supportait très bien les assad père et
fils depuis 30 ans
la conjonction de la sécheresse
croissante dans le pourtour du bassin
méditerranéen et de la mauvaise
connexion aux marchés mondiaux fait que
la syrie par ailleurs a aussi au même
moment un problème de disponibilité
alimentaire et c'est la guerre civile
dont les conséquences sont en train
d'arriver aux portes de l'europe
donc les conséquences du couple énergie
climat sont pas pour dans trois cent
cinquante deux ans c'est pas pour le 1er
janvier 2005 c'est tout de suite là
maintenant c'est déjà en train d'arriver
c'est déjà en train d'arriver voilà donc
voilà un exemple parmi d'autres
on a quelques autres que vous trouverez
dans un excellent livre disponible à la
vente dans quelques mois je suis aussi
capable de vous relier par exemple le
vote populiste à l'énergie je suis aussi
capable de vous là je vous en ai parlé
un petit peu les problèmes financiers
qui a eus aux états unis à l'énergie
enfin tout ça un déterminant énergétique
fort donc une partie des trucs qu'on
croit lié à autre chose
en fait il ya déjà le couple énergie
climat qui est à l'oeuvre sur ce genre
de tournoi l'a écouté le temps le temps
avance et donc je pense qu'on va
s'arrêter là pour le temps d pour les
questions donc nous allons remercier
pour jean marc jancovici pour cette
conférence est passionnante et puis